weiter im Bundestag mit einer aktuellen
Stunde zu den Massakern in Botschaft
beantragt von den von den Koalitionen
der Ampel wir gehen live ins Plenum
145 Millionen Dosen gespendet wir sind
noch nicht ganz so weit es wird noch
eine Frage beantwortet hier im Deutschen
Bundestag in der Fragestunde so heißt
dieser Tagesordnungspunkt den wir im
Moment haben das heißt die Abgeordneten
haben Fragen eingereicht an die
verschiedenen Ministerien und im Moment
ist das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium gefragt und
wir sehen da die Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin Dittmar im Moment die
eine Frage eines Abgeordneten
beantwortet aber in Kürze wird es
weitergehen denn das ist die letzte
Frage die in dieser Fragestunde
thematisiert werden wird hat
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Göring-Eckardt
eben erläutert danach wird die aktuelle
Stunde beginnen diese aktuelle Stunde
wird stattfinden auf Antrag der
Koalitionsfraktionen und der offizielle
Titel ist Massaker der russischen
Truppen an ukrainischen Zivilisten in
butja der Hintergrund das muss ich hier
überhaupt nicht erläutern ist bekannt
das was ich in den vergangenen Wochen
zugetragen hat und was seit wenigen
Tagen bekannt geworden ist in der
ukrainischen Stadt das wird hier
thematisiert werden und natürlich auch
die Folgen und Konsequenzen die daraus
zu ziehen sind koizidenz der Ereignisse
im Anschluss an die Aktuelle Stunde zum
Thema Massaker und zum Krieg gegen die
Ukraine wird es eine Debatte geben zum
30 jahrestag des Kriegsbeginns in
Bosnien und Herzegowina also durchaus
schwierige Themen mit denen sich der
Bundestag hier heute beschäftigt und im
Hintergrund laufen ja auch nach wie vor
noch Gespräche zum Thema Impfpflicht das
dann morgen diskutiert werden wird ab 9
Uhr wir werden natürlich wie gewohnt ab
Viertel von neun für Sie dabei sein und
sie umfänglich informieren es wird ein
etwas anderen aufgeben es wird eine
Reihe namentliche Abstimmung geben und
es gibt beispielsweise einen Brief aus
der
unionsfraktionsspitze dass sich doch
bitteschön alle Abgeordneten der Union
an klare Vorgaben der
Unionsspitze halten nämlich dass man
alle Gesetzentwürfe oder Anträge die
nicht aus dem eigenen aus der eigenen
Fraktion kommen bitte schön konsequent
ablehnen möge jetzt hat Katrin
Göring-Eckardt die sitzt die nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkte aufgerufen und wir
schauen wer hier erste Rednerin oder
erster Redner sein wird Johann David
wadeful den haben wir schon mal gesehen
heute auch bei uns im Programm der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion wird der Erste sein nein
wirklich signalisiert
[Applaus]
Britta Hasselmann für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin
die Bilder und Nachrichten aus Butscher
die uns seit Tagen erreichen sind
schrecklich sie sind grausam die Bilder
von feige ermordeten Menschen von
Massengräbern die Verzweiflung und
Tränen von Müttern und Vätern und
Kindern haben uns alle ins Mark
getroffen
es sind Menschen wie Sie und ich die bis
vor ein paar Wochen noch ein ganz
normales Leben frei und selbstbestimmt
mitten in Europa geführt haben
ich möchte an dieser Stelle dem
Präsidenten selensky und allen
Angehörigen stellvertretend für so viele
Menschen in der Ukraine mein tiefes
Mitgefühl aussprechen
auch hier
meine Damen und Herren herrscht
unfassbare Trauer auch hier herrscht
unfassbare Wut
und auch wenn der Kreml versucht durch
Desinformation Lügen und Propaganda
unbelegte Zweifel zu sehen und seine
Anhänger selbst hier in Deutschland
versuchen diese Zweifel und
Desinformation und Propaganda zu
verbreiten
eins ist doch klar hinter diesen
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
steht Putin und steht seine Armee die
Dokumentation der Kriegsverbrechen und
die Aufarbeitung müssen jetzt beginnen
Putin und seine Gefolgsleute werden sich
dafür vor dem Internationalen
Strafgericht verantworten müssen
meine Damen und Herren
die Morde die Zerstörung und die
Gräueltaten zeigen auf furchtbarste
Weise mit welcher unfassbaren Brutalität
der russische Präsident seinen Krieg
gegen die ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung führt die
Kriegsverbrechen der russischen Armee
können wir nicht unbeantwortet lassen
wir müssen gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen Partnern mit G7 im
transatlantischen Bündnis alles was
möglich ist tun diese unmenschliche
Brutalität einzudämmen der Druck auf
Putin und sein System auf die die ihn
stützen muss dringend erhöht werden ich
hoffe darüber besteht Konsens zwischen
den DemokratInnen und Demokraten dieses
Hauses es kommt jetzt auf ein
gemeinsames entschlossenes europäisches
und internationales Vorgehen an
schärfere Sanktionen werden wir jetzt in
diesen Tagen in diesen Stunden in einem
fünften Sanktionspaket in der
Europäischen Kommission in der
Europäischen Gemeinschaft beschließen um
den Druck auf Putins Machtapparat auf
sein System weiter zu erhöhen dazu
gehören einfuhrverbote für Kohle dazu
gehören transaktionsverbote gegen
wichtige weitere russische Banken ein
weiteres Einfrieren von Vermögenswerten
und einiges mehr was die europäischen
Staaten gemeldet haben und was notwendig
ist die Sanktionen wirklich zu
verschärfen und einfach noch mehr Druck
über dieses Sanktionsregime auszulösen
dieses Paket wird auch das Fundament
sein für einen
Komplettausstieg aus der Abhängigkeit
von Russlands fossiler Energie und damit
das putin-regime auch klar klar noch
härter treffen als ist das mit dem
bisherigen sanktionspaketen den 1-4
schon tut härtere Sanktionen und der Weg
raus aus den fossilen Energien Russlands
werden von den Europäerinnen und
Europäern gemeinsam gegangen und zwar so
schnell wie möglich und das ist die
wichtige Nachricht wir müssen an dieser
Stelle gemeinsam handeln entschlossen
hier und jetzt unser Ziel muss es sein
Russland wirtschaftlich und finanziell
abzukoppeln ohne anderen Ländern zu
Schaden gerade den ärmeren Ländern das
muss uns gelingen diese klare
internationale und europäische Haltung
diese gemeinsame Antwort das ist das
worauf es jetzt ankommt meine Damen und
Herren und dazu gehören auch die
Waffenlieferungen und dazu gehört auch
die die Frage alles was machbar ist im
europäischen Kontext zu diskutieren und
dies auch gemeinsam jetzt auf den Weg zu
bringen im Hinblick auf
wachenlieferungen und das sage ich für
meine Fraktion genauso überzeugt wie
andere hier im Haus und wie wir in der
europäischen gemeinsamen Gemeinschaft
hoffen ich zusammen
put
[Applaus]
inolverbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
sofort stoppen und ich bin mir sicher
wir werden gemeinsam mit unseren
Partnern in Europa im transatlantischen
Bündnis mit der Verschärfung der
Sanktion und mit der Unterstützung zum
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung durch
Waffenlieferung und humanitäre Hilfe
alles was machbar ist tun um diese diese
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit zu
stoppen vielen Dank
Britta Hasselmann Vorsitzende der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Bundestag in der Aktuellen Stunde zu
Massakern der russischen Truppen an
ukrainischen Zivilisten und jetzt kommt
Johann wadeful stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion und
danach die
bundesverteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich kann mich
der Kolleginnen paselmann noch
vollkommen
anschließen das ist nicht nur ein
völkerrechtswidriger Krieg das ist ein
Krieg der unter Verletzung der
Grundnormen der Humanität und der
Verletzung der Grundnormen der Genfer
Konvention geführt wird der keine
Rücksicht mehr nimmt auf schwache
Menschen auf Kinder auf Frauen auf
Schwangere auf altem das ist ein
Krieg der barbarische Art und Weise
geführt wird und in der Tat ich schließe
mich ihre Aufforderung an und bin für
meine Fraktion gerne bereit das zu
erklären hier müssen wir
zusammenstehen und gemeinsam auf der
richtigen Seite stehen und gemeinsam auf
der Seite der Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
stehen meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
ich will aber einräumen Frau Kollegin
dass ich mir so klare Worte wie ich sie
von ihnen gehört habe wie ich sie auch
von Frau stark Zimmermann lese von
Annalena baerborg auch weitgehend höhere
auch vom Bundeskanzler gewünscht hätte
ja ich höre nicht damit auf weil er
vorhin hier Frau esken in einer
Fragestunde Fragen ausgewichen ist
unklar geblieben ist und sich zu dieser
Frage nicht geäußert hat übrigens jede
Woche auch die Gelegenheit hätte klar zu
sagen wofür steht meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren so ein Krieg
kann prinzipiell drei Auswege haben kann
die eine Seite gewinnen das kann die
andere Seite gewinnen und es kann ein
Verständigungsfrieden geben nachdem wir
das letztere in dieser
Auseinandersetzung glaube ich nicht
erwarten können müssen wir uns
entscheiden auf welcher Seite wir mit
welchen Mitteln stehen wollen
und da kann ich nur sagen in dieser
Situation
wir wollten nie wir wollen nicht an dem
Krieg Formel teilnehmen aber in dieser
Situation muss Deutschland muss die
freie Welt wirklich aber auch alles tun
das Putin diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
denn das würde
das würde das würde das wäre eine das
würde eine große Niederlage für uns alle
sein das wäre eine Niederlage für
Deutschland das wäre eine Niederlage für
Menschenrechte das wäre eine Niederlage
für die Europäische Union es wäre
übrigens für alle Staaten auf der Welt
die das unterstützt haben auch in den
Vereinten Nationen an den Niederlage es
wäre eine Niederlage für den Präsidenten
der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und
wir alle oder vielen von uns die
allermeisten von uns ich sage mal die
demokratische Mitte in jedem Fall
wünscht sich ja kaum dass Herr Trump
wieder zum Präsidenten der Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika gewählt wird das
heißt die der Schluss muss doch sein
dass wir jetzt in dieser Situation
wirklich alles tun was in unseren
Möglichkeiten steht in der Tat unterhalb
einer formellenbeteiligung der Natron
der Bundeswehr dass dieser Krieg von den
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern gewonnen
wird dass sie sich erfolgreich
verteidigen können meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
und da muss ich sagen finde ich an der
Stelle Frau esken weil sie es nicht
hören und Herr Bundeskanzler ihre
Antwort von vorhin da musste man ja bei
der dritten Nachfrage versuchen mal
rauszulesen was sagen sie denn nun zum
Thema schwere Waffen es ist eine Binse
man mag es nicht schön finden damals ist
eine militärische Binse das in dieser
Situation des Krieges die Ukrainerinnen
und Ukraine wenn Sie sich erfolgreich
verteidigen sollen schweres Gerät
brauchen gepanzerte Waffen
Bergepanzer
brückenlegepanzer vielleicht sogar
Kampfpanzer vielleicht sogar
Artilleriegeschosse die brauchen sie nun
mal um bestehen zu können
und da muss ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
wenn Ihre Antwort heute hier ist ja da
sollte Deutschland nicht vorbrechen da
sollten wir nicht die ersten sein die
das machen dann ist das aus meiner Sicht
eine unzureichende Antwort dann wird
Deutschland seiner Verantwortung für die
für die Ukraine in dieser historischen
Situation schlicht nicht gerecht meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren das muss
man sagen ja ich will ihnen das ganz
offen sagen ich habe das vorhin in der
Frage gesagt ich kenne Geschäftsführer
von Rüstungsunternehmen die sagen mir
sie haben jede Woche wieder mit einem
Referatsleiter im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium zu tun der
ihn fragen stellt die der Bundeskanzler
hat vorhin auch angedeutet hat können
die Ukraine denn überhaupt mit den
Waffen umgehen wo wollt ihr die
übergeben können die ukraineren Ukraine
das überhaupt bezahlen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wenn wir auf
diesem bürokratischen Niveau am Ende die
ganze Geschichte kaputt machen wollen
dann sagen Sie es bitte ehrlich ich bin
der Meinung wir stehen auf der Seite der
Ukraine und müssen das dann auch leisten
und dazu gehört die Frage der
Energieversorgung die natürlich keine
kleine Frage ist und das will ich auch
nicht abschließend hier sagen dass ich
alles beurteilen kann nur wenn Robert
Habeck sagt also wenn wir das Abschalten
ist es eine Katastrophe aber wenn Putin
das macht dann ist es beherrschbar ist
mindestens mal ein offenkundiger
logischer Widerspruch und deswegen sage
ich diese Bundesregierung muss aus der
Unentschiedenheit herauskommt sie muss
sich klar bekennen sie muss eine
Führungsrolle Unternehmen sie muss wo
sie wissen wo sie steht in dieser
Situation und erst recht nach Butcher an
der Seite der Ukraine an der Seite der
matchmenschlichkeit herzlichen Dank
Johann war der Folie stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der unionsfraktionen
fordert mehr Führung von der
Bundesregierung in der aktuellen Lage
darauf kann jetzt reagieren die
bundesverteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht zuletzt für auftreten und
agieren auch und vor allem mit
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine
wiederholt kritisiert frau Präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
die Bilder die uns aus der Ukraine
erreichen sie sind schrecklich sie
zeigen brutalste Gräueltaten die an
Zivilisten begangen werden und unsere
Gedanken sind bei den Opfern und ihren
Angehörigen und wenn wir ehrlich sind
dann ist dieser Angriffskrieg dieser
proteur brutale Angriffskrieg schon ein
Verbrechen aber das was wir da gesehen
haben was wir da sehen müssen das ist
eine Entmenschlichung die alle Grenzen
überschritten hat
und was klar ist
Putin nimmt diese grauenvollen diese
grausamen Taten in Kauf aber es wäre zu
kurz gesprungen wenn wir das alles nur
auf Putin reduzieren würden es sind
nämlich nicht nur seine Taten sondern
jeder Kommandant der so etwas befehligt
jeder Soldat der so eine Tat ausführt
oder geschehen lässt der macht sich
mindestens genauso schuldig meine Damen
und
alle müssen sich fragen lassen ist das
das Russland für das ihr die Uniform
tragt für das ihr stehen wollt ist das
das Russland für das ihr kämpft und die
internationale Gemeinschaft die muss
klar Antworten jede Tat muss
schonungslos verfolgt werden und es muss
alles dafür getan werden alles das
wirklich jeder einzelne Kriegsverbrecher
auch seine entsprechende harte Strafe
bekommt
aber wir sehen in den Straßen von
Butscher mehr als nur Leichen in deren
Straßen wir sehen im grellen Licht die
Grausamkeit des System Putins es ist ein
System dem alle Mittel recht sind um
seine Interessen durchzusetzen ein
System das nationalistischen großmachts
waren alles unterordnet dass keine
Grenzen kennt und keine Hemmung ein
System das Recht und Menschlichkeit mit
Füßen tritt und deswegen darf dieses
System nicht gewinnen es darf sich nicht
durchsetzen wer so handelt wie Putin dem
ist es egal ob die Leichen auf den
Straßen von Butcher oder Leichen auf den
Straßen von Tiflis Vilnius oder Berlin
sind und daher müssen wir die Ukraine in
ihrem Kampf gegen das System Putin
Stützen unterstützen wo wir nur können
und dabei geht es nicht darum und dabei
geht es nicht darum Schlagzeilen zu
produzieren oder sich Moral zu
erleichtern nein es geht darum ganz
konkret zu helfen ganz konkret zu
unterstützen denn wir können diesen
Krieg so sehr schmerzt nicht mit einem
Schlag beenden und aber wir können wir
können die russische Fähigkeit zur
Kriegsführung Schwächen wir haben
bereits beispiellos harte Sanktionen
erlassen Sanktionen die Russland an das
Rand an den Rand eines staatsbankrotz
gebracht haben und die zunehmend ihre
volle Wirkung auch entfalten und jetzt
werden wir noch einmal entschlossen und
gezielt nachlegen und dabei dann auch
den Import von Energieträgern im Blick
haben ganz aktuell das vorgeschlagene
port-verbot für russische Kohle ist
dabei ein ganz wichtiger Baustein
meine Damen und Herren wir haben die
Ukraine bereits in großem Umfang auch
mit Waffen beliefert unterstützt und wir
arbeiten jeden Tag mit Hochdruck daran
weitere Waffen liefern zu können und
dafür sind wir im ständigen Austausch
mit der ukrainischen Regierung mit
unseren Alliierten und Partnern und auch
mit der Rüstungsindustrie wenn wir über
die Art und Anzahl der gelieferten
Waffen aber nicht öffentlich reden dann
hat das einen guten Grund die Ukraine
hat ausdrücklich drum gebeten und wir
halten uns daran es geht aus
militärischer Sicht nämlich darum dass
Russland im Unklaren über die Typen und
Mengen der gelieferten Waffen ist und
sich nicht darauf einstellen kann der
Feind hört nämlich mit und deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass wir handeln aber
nicht darüber reden weil das würde das
Ziel gefährden nämlich die Ukraine zu
unterstützen
und der badepol und das ist kein keine
bürokratische Hürde in diesem
Zusammenhang ist eins ganz wichtig die
Nato und Deutschland darf nicht
riskieren selbst zur Kriegspartei zu
werden denn das ist für ganz ganz viele
Menschen eine große Sorge momentan wie
geht das weiter wie wirkt sich das aus
was bedeutet das auch für uns wie
entwickelt sich diese Spirale das kann
man nicht einfach als bürokratische
Hürde abtun nein dieser Verantwortung
müssen wir nachkommen und da sind wir
uns mit unseren Verbündeten in der NATO
mit unseren Partnern in der Europäischen
Union sehr sehr einig dass wir diese
Grenze nicht überschreiten wollen und
auch nicht überschreiten werden wir
müssen verhindern dass es einen
Flächenbrand in Europa in Europa gibt
mit allen sich daraus ergebenden
schrecklichen Konsequenzen
meine Damen und Herren das System Putin
darf nicht gewinnen darf sich nicht
durchsetzen denn sonst können wir uns
alle nicht mehr sicher sein und daher
müssen wir auch in Deutschland lernen
sehr viel wehrhafter zu sein sehr viel
wehrhafter zu sein und dieser Gedanke
steht hinter der sicherheitspolitischen
zeitenwände die der Bundeskanzler
verkündet hat dieser Gedanke steht
hinter dem Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro für die Bundeswehr wenn
wir heute in unsere Streitkräfte
investieren dann geht es nämlich darum
unsere Werte von Recht und
Menschlichkeit gegen das System Putin zu
verteidigen da geht es darum uns und
unsere Verbündeten gegen militärische
Erpressung und Gewalt abzusichern vielen
Dank
Christine Lambrecht die
bundesverteidigungsministerin in der
Aktuellen Stunde zu Massakern von
russischen Soldaten den der ukrainischen
Stadt Botschaft und der nächste Redner
ist Jürgen braun aus der afd-fraktion
Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe
frau Präsidentin
liebe Kollegen meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
Butscher war eine ruhige Kleinstadt und
mittelbar vor den Toren Kiews mit einem
großen See und viel grünen das Kiefer
Großbürgertum der vorrevolutionären Zeit
vor dorthin in die Sommerfrische wie man
damals hierzulande gesagt hätte nichts
erinnert jetzt mehr an diese
Vergangenheit denn bis vor wenigen Tagen
sollten Leichen die straßenbotschafts
wie während des holodromore des
kommunistischen Völkermords an den
Ukrainern
natürlich kann in jedem Krieg nicht nur
der Aggressor Kriegsverbrechen begehen
sondern ebenso der Verteidiger wir als
AFD fordern eine zweistufige
Untersuchung zunächst möglichst schnell
durch die drei Experten die der UNO
Menschenrechtsrat erst letzte Woche für
die Ukraine benannt hat der norwegische
schäfermittler dieser Kommission hat
schon das Ruanda Tribunal geleitet und
als zweite Stufe falls die Kommission zu
entsprechenden Ergebnissen gelangt ein
Kriegsverbrecher Tribunal wie zum
ehemaligen Jugoslawien das eine
lückenlose Aufklärung ohne Ansehen der
Kriegspartei leistet
was ist aber jetzt schon gibt sind
Satellitenaufnahmen und Zeugenberichte
Tatjana
wladimirovna eine alte Frau aus Butscher
erzählt wie er Mann getötet wurde drei
Soldaten darunter ein tschechiene
stürmten ihre Wohnung misshandelten und
verschleppten ihn
ihr hattet der chat-schzene mit Schlägen
gedroht falls sie sich widersetzte sie
suchte ihren Mann anschließend tagelang
bei der russischen Armee gab man ihr
keiner Auskunft eine Freundin sagte er
schließlich es seien Leichen im Keller
eines Nachbarhauses gefunden worden
Tatjana erkannte ihren Mann nur an den
Turnschuhen so entstellt war die Leiche
und begraben muss die sie in gemeinsam
mit Freunden denn die russischen Truppen
kümmerten sich nicht einmal darum die
Leichen zu verscharren
die Betrachtung prima facie also der
erste Anschein spricht für die klare
Täterschaft einer bestimmten Seite und
sollte sich das als wahr erweisen dann
muss dieses grausame Handeln
Konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
befragt nach dem Hintergrund solcher
Verbrechen erklärte der Osteuropa
Historiker Jörg barbarowski Zitat die
Soldaten der russischen Armee werden
mangelhaft versorgt leiden Hunger und
frieren sie werden von ihren Offizieren
tyrannisiert Menschen die solcher
Behandlung ausgesetzt sind geraten außer
sich sobald sich ihnen eine Gelegenheit
bietet andere Menschen genauso zu
behandeln
Butcher zeugt davon am 31 März zogen
sich die russischen Streitkräfte zurück
am ersten April nahm die ukrainische
Armee die Stadt ein das erste Video aus
Botschaft noch weitgehend unbeachtet von
den westlichen Medien ist am selben Tag
aufgetaucht und amerikanische
Satellitenaufnahmen zeigen inzwischen
dass die Leichen tagelang dort lagen
trotzdem wird im russischen
Staatsfernsehen behauptet alles sei
arrangiert wird Leichen gar keine
Leichen die ersten Aufnahmen erst Tage
nach der rückereroberung aufgetaucht und
die russische Propaganda wird auch vom
deutschen Staatsfunk genährt der
bundesfaktenchecker Georg Reste der noch
vor kurzem Putin als roalkoalpolitiker
gelobt hat erklärt uns jetzt die
Ukrainer hätten Journalisten keinen
Zugang zu Butcher gewährt dabei hatte
die ARD über Wochen gar keinen eigenen
Reporter in Kiew trotz Zwangsgebühren in
Milliardenhöhe
plötzlich entdeckt auch die nun
oppositionelle CDU ihren
Widerstandsgeist ihre Vorsitzende Angela
Merkel hat doch erst dafür gesorgt das
Deutschland derart abhängig von
russischem Gas wurde und zwar mit ihrem
kopflosen linksgrünen Atomausstieg
und es ist auch Merkels Erbe wenn
Bundeskanzler Scholz der teilweise
swiftabschaltung Russlands erst als
Letzter eu-regierungschef zustimmt so
nach Viktor Orban den sie liebe Kollegen
von der Union jahrelang als putinfreund
beschimpft haben
exemplarisch für den Umgang unserer
Regierung mit dem ukrainekrieg steht
eine Szene aus dem
Menschenrechtsausschuss die ich vor zwei
Wochen miterlebt habe die Kollegin
Engelhardt von der SPD klagte bei einer
Unterrichtung dass die Ukraine
Transfrauen nicht als Frauen sondern als
Männer betrachtet und für sie der
Wehrdienst gelte und die Genossen fragte
erst ernsthaft ob sich die
Bundesregierung dafür einsetze dass die
Ukraine auch Transfrauen als Frauen
anerkennen werde das ist leider kein
Witz
was die Ukraine jetzt braucht sind keine
Belehrungen in Sachen gender das ist
sogar das letzte was sie jetzt braucht
was die Ukraine braucht das ist ein
starkes wehrhaftes Europa der
Vaterländer vielen Dank
Jürgen braun ist Herr Sprecher für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe in
der afd-fraktion und in dieser
afd-fraktion so ist zu hören wird extrem
kontrovers diskutiert über den Umgang
mit Russland und auch mit dem Krieg der
Russen gegen die Ukraine
bijanjir Saray ist der nächste Redner
aus der FDP-Fraktion in der FDP ist ja
Generalsekretär und im Bundestag
Mitglied im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
die grauenvollen Bilder die uns seit dem
vergangenen Wochenende aus Butcher
erreichen sind unerträglich
mit dem Rückzug der russischen Truppen
aus dem Großraum Kiew wird das Ausmaß
der Zerstörung und der Barbarei immer
deutlicher
vor den Augen der ganzen Welt bricht
Putins Russland das Völkerrecht mit
einer Brutalität die ihresgleichen sucht
bis vor einer Woche hatte ich den Namen
Butcher noch nie gehört bis vor einer
Woche bis vor einer Woche wusste ich
nicht einmal wo dieser Ort auf den
Landkarte liegt
ich bin mir aber sicher das künftige
Generation ob in der Ukraine in
Deutschland oder in ganz Europa wissen
werden was in Botschaft passiert ist und
wofür dieser Ort steht Butcher steht für
unfassbar viel Leid Gewalt und
grauenhafte Verbrechen
Satellitenbildern zufolge liegen dort
die toten Männer Frauen und Kinder seit
Wochen auf dem Straßen teilweise
gefesselt geknebelt
und mit Spuren von Vergewaltigungen
Ohnmacht Angst Hilflosigkeit noch immer
habe ich das Gesicht von Präsident
selenski vor Augen der mit ausländischen
Journalisten durch Butcher geht damit
diese der Welt zeigen können welche
grausamen Massaker an unschuldigen
Zivilisten begangen wurden
sein Gesichtsausdruck
spiegelt all jene Gefühle wieder die so
viele ukrainische Mütter Väter und
Angehörige in diesen Tagen schmerzhaft
durchleben
die Toten von Butcher sie alle hatten
Freunde und Verwandte sie alle waren
Menschen mit Träumen und sorgen für das
Leben sie alle hatten individuelle
Biografien und sie alle waren
einzigartig
ich weiß nicht was wir noch für Bilder
zu sehen bekommen werden
aber ich befürchte dass die grausamen
Bilder aus Butcher nur die Spitze des
Eisberges sind
meine Damen und Herren in den letzten
Tagen ist viel über die deutsche
Auslosung Sicherheitspolitik gesprochen
worden sehr oft habe ich in den letzten
Tagen gehört dass wir alle naiv
gegenüber Russland gewesen sind und
Putin falsch eingeschätzt haben diese
Fehler dürfen sich nicht wiederholen und
gerade jetzt in dieser Situation dürfen
wir erst recht nicht naiv sein der
Westen
der Westen hat nach dem Georgienkrieg
nicht entschlossen gegenüber Putin
reagiert der Westen hat nicht
geschlossen auf die krim-anlektion
reagiert der Westen hat sich im
Wesentlichen weggedreht als Russland in
Syrien ganze Städte und Dörfer
ausradiert hat wir müssen uns darüber im
Klaren sein solange dieses Regime
existiert meine Damen und Herren wird es
keine Sicherheit in Europa geben
nirgendwo
künftige künftige Generationen werden
uns die Frage stellen egal ob Regierung
oder
Opposition
werden uns die Frage stellen wie wir uns
in diesem schicksalsstunden Europas
verhalten haben wir sind es nicht nur
den Opfern dieses Krieges schuldig wir
sind es uns auch selbst schuldig
jede Form der wirtschaftlichen
Zusammenarbeit mit diesem Regime ist
eine Schande und muss schnellstmöglich
beendet werden meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland und Europa zeigen sich in
dieser dunklen Stunde der europäischen
Geschichte solidarisch mit der Ukraine
nicht nur mit schönen Worten auch mit
Taten
weitere Taten und Handlungen müssen
folgen eine breit gefächerte
Unterstützung der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte ist von äußerster
Wichtigkeit
an klar zu machen dass die Beziehung zum
Westen endgültig zu Bruch gegangen ist
solange Putin die Macht im Kreml
innerhalb
die Welt wird die Gräueltaten von
Butcher niemals vergessen
wir werden und müssen alles dafür tun
dass die dass die Verantwortlichen für
diese Verbrechen zu Rechenschaft gezogen
werden meine Damen und Herren Putin hat
versucht mit ein brutalen Angriffskrieg
die Ukraine zu vernichten und den Westen
zu spalten das ist ihm nicht gelungen
meine Damen und Herren und das wird ihm
auch nicht gelingen
wir stehen fest an der Seite aller
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer die in diesen
schweren Tagen um ihre Freiheit um ihr
Leben kämpfen salva Ukraine
Slava Ukraine
für die für die Linke ergreift der
Kollege Dr Dietmar Bartos fort und damit
spricht jetzt der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linksfraktion hier in deutschen
Bundestag frau Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren die Bilder aus Butcher sind
unerträglich tote Männer Frauen Kinder
kaltblütig ermordet auf offener Straße
auf dem Fahrrad unschuldige Bürgerinnen
und Bürger auf der Straße Lieder liegen
gelassen in Massengräbern verscharrt
aus den Butcher getan wurde ist ein
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit es
sind Kriegsverbrechen die
Verantwortlichen für diese Barbarei
gehören schonungslos ermittelt sie
müssen vor allem Gericht für foltern und
für ihr Morden zur Verantwortung gezogen
worden und dafür müssen wir alles tun
meine Damen und Herren
die politische Verantwortung die
politische Verantwortung für die Toten
von Butcher trägt Vladimir Putin ich
wiederhole heute hier russlands
Präsident ist ein Kriegsverbrecher seine
Entscheidung am 24 februar die Ukraine
zu überfallen hat den Grundstein für die
Verbrechen gelegt die seit diesem Tag
die Ukraine heimsuchen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Butscher
bestürzt und auch deshalb weil sich das
Grauen abbildet weil uns Fotos und
Videos erreichen weil Augenzeugen
schildern welche Gräuel begangen wurden
und ich will uns alle mal ermahnen eine
Sekunde an die vielen geflüchteten zu
denken die diese Bilder auch sehen und
die vielfach jetzt schon traumatisiert
sind ich glaube das sollten wir bei uns
und Argumenten auch mit beachten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen machen wir uns
nichts vor Butcher ist nicht der Ort von
Kriegsverbrechen butchers ein Ort von
Kriegsverbrechen weitere Bilder des
Horrors werden uns erreichen wenn
Journalistinnen und Journalisten in
andere Orte und Städte der Ukraine
vordringen wenn die wenigen Bilder sieht
die uns aus Mario Pohl zum Beispiel
erreichen ahnt welche Dramatik wir noch
zu erwarten haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen um das
hier zu sagen die Verantwortung für den
Krieg und die Verbrechen trägt Russland
niemand in Deutschland deswegen will ich
das klar sagen das Angela Merkel und
Frank-Walter Steinmeier von einigen die
ich ansonsten viel zu kritisieren hatte
von einigen zu Helfershelfern das
russischen Präsidenten erklärt werden
das ist zutiefst unanständig und das ist
auch beschämt meine Damen und Herren es
geht hier nicht um Schlagzeilen wer
versucht nämlich den Krieg in der
Ukraine parteipolitisch zu
instrumentalisieren der leistet keinen
Beitrag den Krieg zu beenden sondern er
spielt der russischen Propaganda eines
gespaltenen Westens in die Karten meine
Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Verbrechen dieses Krieges werden enden
wenn dieser verbrecherische Krieg endet
denn kriegsverpressen Kriegsverbrechen
sind kriegen immer nennt und zwar allen
Kriegen mein Eindruck ist das eine hier
davon ausgehen dass der Krieg in wenigen
Wochen beendet sein kann dass es die
eine exportierte Waffe gibt oder die
eine Sanktion die Putin zur Kapitulation
zwingt ich halte das offen gestanden für
wenig wahrscheinlich dieser Krieg kann
auch noch lange andauern und da hilft es
auch nicht jeden Tag lieber Kollege
wadefohlen mit der Rüstungsindustrie
Kontakt zu haben das ist etwas
entlarvend das hier so zu sagen meine
Damen und Herren wir befinden uns in
einem moralischen Dilemma ganz gleich ob
wir Energieimporte den Krieg nur direkt
oder indirekt finanzieren
aber erklären Sie mir doch bitte einen
Sachverhalt der vorhin schon in der
Fragestunde eine Rolle spielt sehr
geehrter Bundeskanzler warum schafft es
Belgien
Vermögenswerte russischer Oligarchen in
Höhe von 10 Milliarden Euro einzufrieren
warum schafft es Frankreich 850
Millionen einzufrieren Italien hat
mehrere hundert Millionen Euro
beschlagnahmt und Deutschland liegt bei
95 Millionen das doch unfassbar warum
funktioniert das denn nicht warum
versagt Deutschland bei der Durchsetzung
der Sanktionen gegen russische
Oligarchen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die ard-recherche also
Kontraste nach der haben russische
Investoren allein in Berlin seit 2014
und wir alle wissen was 2014 war
Immobilien im Wert von 442 Millionen
erworben und sie stehen aktuell bei 95
Millionen für ganz Deutschland
beschlagnahmtes Vermögen das ist
wirklich unfassbar weil sie haben am 15
März eine Task Force gegründet dass der
richtig und zuständig sind die
Ministerien von Herrn harberg und Herrn
Linder man hört relativ viel von den
beiden Herren nur dazu über überhaupt
nichts und das muss ich ändern herr
Scholz machen sie das zur Chefsache die
Verantwortung dafür gehört ins
Kanzleramt dieses Geld muss für den
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine eingesetzt
werden meine Damen und Herren ja lassen
Sie uns alles tun dass der Krieg beendet
wird nur das wird Verbrechen wie die in
Butcher auch beenden herzlichen Dank
Dietmar Bartsch war das hier der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linksfraktion
in dieser aktuellen Stunde auf die sich
die Abgeordneten des Deutschen
Bundestags geeinigt haben zu
Massakern an ukrainischen Zivilisten in
Botschaft und Kollegen und ich erteile
das Wort dem nächsten Redner Michael
Roth SPD-Fraktion und Michael Roth ist
Vorsitzender des Auswärtigen Ausschusses
vielen Dank liebe Frau Präsidentin
Kollegin und Kollegen
Butscher wird sich sicherlich tief in
das kollektive Gedächtnis nicht nur der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer sondern von
uns allen den Europäerinnen und
Europäern einbrennen
aber vergessen wir nicht
Butcher steht nicht für sich allein
Butcher hat eine Vorgeschichte es ist
Aleppo es ist krosny es sind viele
andere Orte wo Putin in aller Brutalität
gezeigt hat wozu er bereit und imstande
ist um seine Interessen knallhart
entmenschlicht durchzusetzen und wir
erleben derzeit auch in der Ukraine
selbst viel zu viele Orte wo tagtäglich
Zivilistin und solivellisten einen
furchtbaren Tod sterben aber liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieser
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine war von
Anfang an
verbrecherisch
frevelhaft verwerflich und grausam
und es ist sehr bitter die sagen zu
müssen
es ist nicht nur putinskrieg
viele Russinnen und Russen unterstützen
Putin und das sagt er ja so selbst in
seinem Kampf um die Befreiung der
Ukraine vom Faschismus wie furchtbar und
wie schlimm muss das vor allem auch in
unseren Augen und in unseren Ohren
klingen
und das wird bittere Konsequenzen haben
der niemand kann sich darauf einstellen
dass dieses furchtbare Regime unter
Führung von Putin so schnell aus den
Angeln gehoben werden wird sondern wir
werden uns auf absehbare Zeit vermutlich
noch mit diesem Regime
auseinanderzusetzen haben und es wird
darum gehen ob die Europäische Union die
Demokratien die Liberalen Gesellschaften
diese Macht
einzuheben in der Lage sind
über die Zukunft Europas wird in diesen
Tagen Wochen und Monaten nicht in Berlin
nicht in Paris nicht in Rom nicht ins
Stockholm sondern in mariopol in schakev
ohne Butcher entschieden wenn Russland
diesen furchtbaren Krieg gewinnen sollte
dann Thron weitere militärische
Konflikte in Moldau in Georgien
möglicherweise auch in anderen Staaten
des östlichen Europas es zieht sich bis
in den westlichen Balkan wo wir derzeit
sezessionsbeschreibungen
Bosnien-Herzegowina erleben die aktiv
und völlig unmoralisch und völlig kalt
und brutal von Protein unterstützt
werden Frieden und Sicherheit in ganz
Europa auch unsere eigene Sicherheit in
Deutschland
ist nur dann möglich wenn die Ukraine
frei und souverän bleibt
Putin hat diesen Krieg zwar moralisch
wirtschaftlich politisch längst verloren
aber er muss und er wird ihn auch
militärisch verlieren und das wird
maßgeblich davon abhängen wie wir die
Ukraine in diesen dramatischen Zeiten
unterstützen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aus fast allen Fraktionen
gehen derzeit Abgeordnete unserer
Regierung auf die Nerven
wir sind ungeduldig wir fragen uns
tagtäglich in jeder Stunde was können
wir noch mehr tun wo müssen wir noch
aktiver werden wo können wir noch mehr
humanitäre Hilfe leisten wo können wir
noch mehr für den Schutz der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer tun ja wo
können wir auch noch mehr militärische
Unterstützung leisten und dabei geht es
um alle Waffen die die Ukraine benötigt
die schnell und sicher geliefert werden
können und die eben auch leicht
bedienbar sind damit sich die Ukraine zu
verteidigen vermag jeden Tag den die
Ukraine länger frei und souverän bleibt
werden Chancen für eine Lösung am
Verhandlungstisch wahrscheinlicher nur
aus einer Position der Stärke und der
Wehrhaftigkeit heraus hat die Ukraine
eine Chance zu überleben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und es mag ein schwacher Trost sein aber
ich will es trotzdem wenigstens einmal
gesagt haben was uns gemeinsam gelungen
ist ist das die europäische und die
Europäische Union die NATO geschlossen
und entschlossen zusammenstehen so viel
Teamgeist hat es vermutlich schon seit
vielen Jahren und Jahrzehnten in diesem
vereinten Europa nicht mehr gegeben
machen wir etwas daraus und vor allem
muss das jetzt auch für die weiteren
Sanktionen gelten wir müssen uns hier
auf fragen was können wir tun um noch
mehr Druck auf Russland auf Putin auf
die Oligarchen ausüben zu können und ich
finde es ist die Pflicht der
Bundesregierung alle Maßnahmen auf
soziale wirtschaftliche politische
Folgen hin zu überprüfen das wird uns
bisweilen in ein furchtbares moralisches
Dilemma bringen aber es muss klar sein
dass am Ende wir auch zu weitreichenden
Entscheidungen bereit sind aber wir
müssen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
unseres Landes nehmen nur ein starkes
Deutschland kann Europa bei dieser
Bewährungsprobe helfen und nur ein
starkes Deutschland ist im übrigen auch
gut für die Ukraine denn nur dann kommen
Sie bitte zum Schluss herum können wir
die Solidarität ausüben um die wir immer
wieder gebeten werden und wir sollten
die ausgestreckte Hand der Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainer in größter Not annehmen das
ist unsere Pflicht und das ist unsere
Schuldigkeit
Michael Roth war das hat hier
gesprochene Vorsitzende des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses seit Beginn des Ukraine
Krieges ist die Debatte in Deutschland
welche Waffen geliefert werden ob Waffen
geliefert werden und bisher hieß es
immer schwere Waffen wie Panzer oder
auch Kriegsschiffe kommen nicht in Frage
diese Debatte ist aber durch die
Gräueltaten jetzt wieder in vollen Gange
frau Präsidentin Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ist das das Bild der rot lackierten
Fingernägel einer ermordeten Frau
ist das der Schlüsselbund mit
Europafahne neben der Hand eines
weiteren ermordeten Zivilisten oder ist
es doch die laut tönende Sprachlosigkeit
Präsident selenskys in Butcher die uns
ebenso fassungs wie sprachlos macht es
sind Blicke auf schwerste
Menschenrechtsverletzung und schlimmste
Kriegsverbrechen die uns aus der Ukraine
erreichen und nicht nur sie zeigen es
geht bei diesem Angriffskrieg von Putin
und seinen Schergen um die systematische
Zerstörung eines ganzen Volkes einer
freiheitlichen Nation hier ist ein
Kriegsverbrecher am Werk der keine
Grenzen mehr kennt
nur 45 100 Kilometer von butja entfernt
liegt auch babinha
1941 ermordete hier die ISS tausende
jüdische Männer und Frauen und Kinder
vor genau 30 Jahren nachher kommt die
Debatte noch in diesem Haus begann die
Belagerung der bosnischen Hauptstadt
Sarajevo was folgte war das schreckliche
sterben franz reprinica
haben wir das noch alles in Erinnerung
deshalb Kolleginnen und Kollegen geht
doch heute umso mehr die Situation in
der Ukraine ist fundamental und
historisch der Ausgang dieses Krieges
hat vor allem Auswirkungen für die
Menschen dort aber auch für unsere
eigene Zukunft EU NATO und weite Teile
der Staatengemeinschaft stehen zusammen
ein Sanktionspaket folgt dem nächsten
und ja Frau Lamprecht ist gilt kein
eigenes militärisches einschreiten um
einen noch größeren Weltenbrand zu
verhindern aber dann müssen wir doch
diejenigen die am Ende auch unsere
Freiheit verteidigen und das ist
wörtlich zu nehmen in die Lage umfassend
versetzen dies tun zu können
auch unser Land tut vieles sicher allein
die Hilfsbereitschaft unzählige Menschen
in diesem Land ist unschätzbar aber ich
stelle dennoch die Frage kann diese
Bundesregierung mit ruhigem Gewissen
sagen wir tun wirklich alles um Putin zu
stoppen muss man nicht viel mehr sagen
von Anfang an stand der Eindruck im Raum
Deutschland reagiert mehr als es agiert
und das oft auch nur aus Druck von außen
zumeist auf den letzten Metern bis heute
die Regierung hat beschlossen Waffen zu
liefern so der Bundeskanzler vor wenigen
Minuten an anderer Stelle noch hier in
diesem Hause das ist gut aber Herr
Bundeskanzler zur Wahrheit gehört doch
aus dass wir es erst getan haben als
alle anderen Partner bereits ihre Waffen
auf den Weg gebracht hatten das gehört
zur Wahrheit dazu wir liefern zu wenig
zu langsam und zu spät Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die weitere Entwicklung in
diesem Krieg werden schneller sein als
wir das ahnen wir doch jetzt schon auch
beim Thema Energie ist dieses Land ist
diese Regierung darauf vorbereitet
deshalb liefern sie umgehend die Waffen
die die Ukraine jetzt benötigt und nicht
die Sie gegebenenfalls selbst für
sinnvoll halten es ist möglich von allem
setzen Sie sich bei allen Sanktionen an
die Spitze der Bewegung das ist keine
Hybris es wird von uns erwartet aktuell
prüfen Sie ein eigenes Gesetz ob sie es
machen müssen um Rechtssicherheit zu
bekommen bei der Umsetzung der
Sanktionen okay aber Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben in der Zwischenzeit
das fünfte Sanktionspaket und jetzt
fängt Deutschland an zu prüfen ob wir
diese überhaupt rechtssicher umsetzen
können kein Wunder dass sie Fragen
gestellt bekommen hier aus diesem Hause
bezüglich der Vermögenswerte und wie
viel Salz sie davon schon ein konnten
der Ukraine hingegen der läuft die Zeit
davon Putin darf diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen darüber sind wir uns hier alle
einig aber dann übernehmen sie sichtbar
Verantwortung und Führung in Deutschland
in Europa in der Gemeinschaft unserer
Partner vielen Dank
Patricia lips fordert hier zur Eile auf
nächster Redner ist Jürgen Trittin er
ist der außenpolitische Sprecher von
Bündnis 90 den Grünen hier im Deutschen
Bundestag
und der nächste Redner der Debatte ist
Jürgen Trittin Bündnis 90 die Grünen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
von Clausewitz stammt der Satz des Krieg
nur die Fortsetzung der Politik mit
anderen Mitteln sein welche Politik
wurde in buccia mit Morden an Kindern an
Frauen an alten mit Folter mit
Vergewaltigung fortgesetzt dort in
Botschaft setzte das russische Militär
Putins Politik um Putin der im Juli
davon sprach die Ukraine bedürfe keine
Eigenstaatlichkeit es gebe eine
einheitliche Nation von kleinen Russen
so nannte er die Ukraine von belorussen
und Russen
der genau dieses auf dem Weg gebracht
haben in butja wurden aus Putins
Ankündigungen Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit
und
diese Verantwortung müssen wir klar
benennen unter dem Vorwand die Ukraine
von einem jüdischen Präsidenten
entnazifizieren zu wollen
kopiert die russische Soldateska die
Methoden der Einsatzgruppen der
deutschen Wehrmacht der SS und der
deutschen Polizei bei ihrem Überfall auf
die Ukraine das ist die Realität vor der
wir stehen
und natürlich Michael Roth hat recht
niemand darf davon überrascht sein der
brosny gesehen hat der Aleppo der iClip
gesehen hat
aber ich muss noch etwas hinzufügen
auch an uns alle und jenseits der
Parteien
Anfang der 2000er haben viele geglaubt
mit Putin käme ein neuer Peter der Große
nach Russland doch die Russen haben
nicht Wohlstand nicht Modernisierung
erfahren im Gegenteil ihnen wurde nur
Nationalismus und Gewalt geboten nicht
Peter der Große Wladimir der
schreckliche ist in diesen Europa am
Arbeiten
wir haben
uns auch geirrt
wir haben geirrt in dem denk als wir
geglaubt haben man könnte so jemanden
mit ökonomischen Mitteln abschrecken
Putin schätze ich nicht um ökonomische
Abschreckung der versteht nur die
Abschreckung durch Militär und Gewalt
deswegen die 100 Milliarden deswegen die
Erhöhung der Präsenz an der Ostflanke
deswegen die Waffenlieferung an die
Ukraine aber wir müssen auch einen
anderen Irrtum beenden den Irrtum das
Wandel geschaffen wird durch handeln
wir haben die russischen Banken vom
Zahlungsverkehr abgeklemmt wir haben die
russische Zentralbank von der
Währungsreserven abgeschnitten es sind
die schärfsten finanzamtionen die je
verhängt worden sind wir haben uns jetzt
in Europa entschieden endlich sage ich
keine Kohle mehr importieren zu wollen
Deutschland arbeitet daran dass kein Öl
mehr nach Schwedt kommt wir arbeiten
daran unseren gastverbrauch zu
reduzieren wir legen das Paket vor dass
sie endgültig raus wollen aus fossilen
Energien weil wir wissen nur wenn wir
erneuerbare Energien schnell ausbauen
schaffen wir Energiesicherheit und
beenden unsere Abhängigkeit
aber meine Damen und Herren glaubt
eigentlich jemand dass wir das jemals
wieder rückgängig machen werden nein das
werden wir nicht deswegen sollten wir
aufhören von Sanktionen zu sprechen was
hier stattfindet ist nichts anderes als
die Abkopplung Russlands von den Märkten
Europas von den Märkten der USA die
Abkopplung von den Märkten der G7
Staaten darum geht es wir schicken das
Russland von Wladimir dem schrecklichen
zurück in die Zeit der 60er Jahre des
letzten Jahrhunderts das ist das woran
wir arbeiten
und ich muss ein letztes hinzufügen
meine Damen und Herren
wir dürfen keine dieser Morde vergessen
keiner dieser Mörder darf straffrei
ausgehen das schulden wir den Opfern
ihren Familien und ihren Freunden das
ist der Grund warum wir alles tun werden
zusammen mit der Beauftragten für
Menschenrechte dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof Beweise zu sichern
und die Verantwortlichen auch
tatsächlich vor Gericht zu bringen wir
müssen eines aus dieser Geschichte der
Gewalt noch gelernt haben
Straffreiheit für Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit ist Beihilfe dies müssen
wir beenden und wir müssen klar sagen
es gibt eine nur eine wirkliche
Botschaft aus Botschaft beenden Sie
diesen Krieg ziehen Sie die russischen
Truppen aus der Ukraine ab
der Appell von Jürgen Trittin aus dem
politischer Sprecher der Grünen Fraktion
hier im Deutschen Bundestag eine
Aktuelle Stunde auf die sich hier die
Abgeordneten geeinigt haben noch ist
unklar wie groß das Ausmaß dessen ist
was dort wirklich in dieser Stadt im
Nordwesten von Kiew passiert ist das
wird sich in den nächsten Wochen
vielleicht aber auch erst Monaten Zeiten
die nächste Rednerin in dieser Debatte
ist Renate alt Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe nun Kollegen am 6 März
besetzten die russischen Truppen das
Dorf wossel ca 50 km nordwestlich von
Kiew
sie warfen eine Nebelkerze in den Keller
eines Gebäudes in dem mehrere Zivilisten
Schutz vor dem schweren Beschuss suchten
als eine Frau und ein 14-jähriges
Mädchen aus dem Keller rauskamen
schossen die russischen Soldaten auf die
beiden das Kind starb auf der Stelle die
Frau erlag ihren Verletzungen zwei Tage
später das ist nur einer von mehreren
Dutzend Berichten der Augenzeugen die
human reizwatch inzwischen in der
Ukraine sammeln konnte meine Damen und
Herren die Bilder aus Butter und anderen
Vororten von herrlich karkif und Kiew
sind eine Zäsur
nach dem was dort passiert ist wird es
kein Zurück mehr zum Business as usual
mit Putins Russland geben
Kriegsverbrechen der russischen Armee
müssen geahndet werden wir haben
weggeschaut als großen nie den Boden
gleichgemacht wurde wir haben
weggeschaut als Zivilisten im syrischen
ostguter massakriert wurden viel
schlimmer noch ab dem ersten Tag des
russischen Überfalls auf die Ukraine gab
es Berichte von Kriegsverbrechen von
zerstörter zivilen Infrastruktur von
beschossenen humanitären Konvois vom
bombardamar der Geburtsklinik in Mario
Paul nach Butcher muss jetzt
entschlossen gehandelt werden wir müssen
jetzt eine totale wirtschaftliche
Isolation Russland anstreben
es geht aber nicht nur darum Druck auf
das russische Regime zu erhöhen die
Täter müssen zur Rechenschaft gezogen
werden die Verbrechen die schon jetzt
von Menschenrechtlern genannt werden
umfassen Vergewaltigungen
willkürliche Hinrichtungen Gewalt gegen
Zivilisten Plünderungen und Folter je
mehr ukrainische Orte befreit werden
desto mehr Bilder wie die aus Butter
sind leider zu erwarten
russische Entscheidungsträger und
Offiziere die dieser Gräueltaten
zugelassen oder angeordnet haben haben
das Kriegsrecht mit Füßen getreten sie
haben das humanitäre Völkerrecht und die
genferkonventionen aber auch das
internationale Besatzungsrecht auf
gröbste verletzt die strafrechtliche
Verantwortlichkeit für diese Gräueltaten
erfordert Beweise die den Stand von
fairem Gerichtsverfahren standhalten die
Ukraine kann zu einem Wendepunkt in der
Dokumentation von
krebsverbrechen werden es gibt kaum
einen Krieg bei dem Beweise von
Kriegsverbrechen so früh und so genau
gesammelt wurden die mutigen
ukrainischen Beamten und lokale
zivilgesellschaftliche Gruppen die in
belagerten Städten und Ortschaften tätig
sind riskieren ihr Leben um diesen Krieg
jetzt zu dokumentieren sie haben
Menschenrechtsorganisationen und Open
Source Forscher an ihrer Seite ihren
allen gebührt unser größter Respekt
aus allen muss klar sein jede
Journalistin jeder Kameramann vor Ort
riskiert sein Leben unsere Aufgabe ist
jetzt beim Festhalten der Beweise zu
helfen Deutschland sollte die
Kommissionen und entios beisammen der
Daten unterstützen den Open Source und
digital Forensikern müssen wir
Plattformen geben damit sie ihre
Erfahrungen bei Untersuchungen aus
früheren Konflikten austauschen können
internationale Ermittler müssen darin
geschult werden wie Open Source Beweise
eingesetzt werden können technische
Ausrüstung Satellitenbilder digitale
Infrastruktur wir müssen helfen wo es
nur geht
meine Damen und Herren Butter ist ein
Wendepunkt und jetzt müssen wir parallel
zu allen Sanktionen zu jeglichem Druck
alles dafür tun dass russische Soldaten
bald von nationalen und internationalen
Gerichten stehen
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das Wort Michel
Müntefering SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Eltern
wollten schon immer ein Haus kaufen in
Botschaft weil es so nah dran ist an
Kiew man mit dem Auto in die Hauptstadt
pendeln kann wie viele Diplomaten und
manche Abgeordnete Butcher unser Tor in
die Hauptstadt es war eine schöne Stadt
erzählt mir gestern eine junge
Ukrainerin das Leid den Schrecken all
das kann sie kaum fassen sie sieht die
Bilder von Herne aus von meiner
Heimatstadt aus dem Ruhrgebiet wo sie
einen sicheren Ort gefunden hat der
Preis dafür alleine gehen die Familie
dem Schicksal überlassen das Schicksal
das ist die russische Aggression Putins
völkerrechtswidriger Krieg es ist
richtig dass heute angesichts der
Ereignisse der letzten Tage noch einmal
ganz deutlich wird wir hier stehen an
der Seite der Ukraine
Krieg
Krieg bringt tot erkennt keine Gewinner
Krieg ist das unmenschlichste das
Menschen geschaffen haben alle
Bemühungen ihn Regeln zu unterwerfen in
Völkerrecht Kriegsrecht einzubeten ihn
zu erklären zu zügeln zu bändigen ihn in
Grenzen zu halten ihn auf militärische
Kräfte zu beschränken sein Schrecken
bleibt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
Butscher sehen wir auf grausamste Art
und Weise was kriege niemals dürfen
Vergehen an Frauen Kindern alten kranken
gefangen gefoltert vergewaltigt getötet
sie gehören zur Zivilgesellschaft
Präsident Putin verbieten sie ihren
Soldaten diese Gräueltaten klar und
öffentlich noch heute lassen sie Waffen
schweigen beenden Sie den Krieg ziehen
sie alle ihre Truppen aus der Ukraine ab
wenn es kein Mitleid ist dass sie
aufbringen können dann haben Sie
vielleicht ein letztes bisschen
Ehrgefühl nicht unter den schlimmsten
und Verbrechern der Menschheit in die
Geschichtsbücher einzugehen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen für uns
gilt wir müssen jetzt noch mehr tun denn
wer nach Botschaft schaut ja der muss
auch in andere Städte schauen nach
ihrpin oder Gusto Mel Städte in den
früher viele Menschen lebten die in Kiew
arbeiteten viele Städte ihre Bewohner im
Nordwesten von Kiew haben unter den
Verbrechen der russischen Armee gelitten
die auf ihrem Weg eine Spur der
Verwüstung hinterlässt human white
Swatch one warnt dass es ähnliche
Gewaltexzesse in anderen Städten gibt
die Gräuel sie müssen aufgeklärt werden
sie brauchen eine klare Antwort und ich
bin unserem Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
dankbar der hier übrigens heute sitzt
und sich erklärt hat und uns zuhört
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin
unserem Bundeskanzler dankbar dass er
deutlich gemacht hat wir schauen nicht
tatenlos zu wir helfen es ist richtig
dass die EU weitere Sanktionen verhängen
will das Angehörige der russischen bot
so unerwünschten Personen erklärt worden
sind die hier bei uns gegen uns
gearbeitet haben es braucht aber mehr
und einiges ist angesprochen worden ich
meine den Zugang für internationale
Organisationen zu den Gebieten um die
Gräueltaten unabhängig zu dokumentieren
die Täter ja Sie müssen zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden die Bundesregierung
sollte auch den Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof finanziell stärken wir
müssen in der EU eine eigene Kapazität
schaffen um zu helfen diese Verbrechen
aufzuklären die Oligarchen sie müssen
gestoppt werden über alle Wege
überscheinen Firmen und ähnliches die
Sanktionen zu umgehen und ja wir müssen
europäisch koordinieren wie wir aus den
russischen Energieimporten aussteigen
wir müssen raus aus russischer Energie
aus Kohle Öl und Gas in Stufen aber so
schnell es irgend geht nicht zuletzt
muss sich die Ukraine wehren und
verteidigen können ich habe in die
Listen über die Waffenlieferungen in der
geheime Schulstelle Einsicht genommen
und ich kann sagen das ist eine
deutliche Entwicklung in den letzten
Wochen echte Unterstützung das ist gut
dass es richtig danke auch dafür
würde mir
[Applaus]
Wünschens Leistungen aus anderen Häusern
für die Abgeordneten in aller in voller
Transparenz koordiniert zur Verfügung
gestellt werden denn das brauchen wir
auch als Grundlage für unsere Diskussion
hier klar ist die Ukraine braucht jetzt
für die Verteidigung auch weitere
Waffenlieferungen solche die schnell
verfügbar die schnell einsetzbar sind
und wir werden jetzt auch mit unseren
Partnern uns darauf einstellen müssen
der Ukraine nicht nur den Arm zu stärken
sondern auch den Rücken die Ukraine
braucht unsere Solidarität aber auch in
Zukunft alle Kraft zur
Selbstverteidigung herzlichen Dank
die Rede von Michelle Müntefering aus
der SPD-Fraktion der Bundesregierung
liegen mittlerweile auch schon beleget
dafür vor dass es sich bei den Tötungen
von Zivilisten handelt dass es sich hier
um Kriegsverbrechen handelt so hat es
mittlerweile auch der Regierungssprecher
bestätigt Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Bilder die wir täglich sehen sind
schockierend die Ukraine muss sich gegen
einen brutalen Angriffskrieg gegen
schrecklichste Kriegsverbrechen zur Wehr
setzen mutige Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
stehen an der Front in der direkten
militärischen Auseinandersetzung aber
angegriffen wurde nicht nur die Ukraine
angegriffen wurde ganz Europa und das
meine Damen und Herren muss auch
wirklich wieder in unserem Land
verstehen dass wir uns es nicht einfach
weiter bequem machen können während die
niedermiete Menschen in Ukraine sterben
und darauf darf selbstverständlich auch
der ukrainische Botschafter andere
mellik Hinweisen den manche hier
kritisieren der unbequem ist auch für
uns aber dem ich danke dass er in dieser
schrecklichen Situation in dieser Lage
in der sein Land ist die bestmögliche
Unterstützung für sein Land erreichen
will
meine Damen und Herren
Butcher war ein Zivilisationsbruch
Rutscher reiht sich ein in die
schwersten Kriegsverbrechen in Europa
ein schauderhafte Abgründe von denen wir
ausgingen dass wir sie in Europa nie
wieder haben werden ganze Familien auf
offener Straße erschossen für nichts
ganze Dörfer ausgelöscht für nichts
ganze Landstriche verwüstet für nichts
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wieso
lassen wir es zu dass aus dem nie wieder
ein schon wieder in Europa geworden ist
und es stehen schlimmste Wochen bevor
die ukrainische Regierung hat vor kurzem
vor wenigen Momenten
aufgerufen die ostukarine zu verlassen
die Zivilbevölkerung zu evakuieren wegen
der erwarteten
Großoffensive und da helfen letztendlich
nur
entsprechende Verteidigungsfähigkeit wir
müssen endlich alles dafür tun dass
dieser Kriegsverbrecher Putin gestoppt
wird und da muss ich ehrlich sagen
ist da muss ich ehrlich sagen meine
Damen und Herren ist die Zögerlichkeit
dieser Bundesregierung in vielen Fragen
nicht zu ertragen wir haben als
Opposition gesagt dass wir die Regierung
unterstützt in allem was sie tut um
diesen Krieg zu stoppen aber wir können
natürlich nicht das Nichtstun
unterstützen ich finde wichtig Herr
Bundeskanzler dass sie zu dieser
aktuellen Stunde gekommen sind
aber jetzt vorher bei der Fragestunde
sicher hinzustellen und sagen dass diese
Regierung schließlich macht Waffen
liefert was die vorherige nicht gemacht
hat das ist zu wenig weil man muss
natürlich gemessen werden an der
Situation in der wir sind und Frau
Verteidigungsministerin das ist kein
überzeugendes Bild das sie abgeben
Geheimhaltung kann kein Feigenblatt für
Untätigkeit sein meine Damen und Herren
und das
das ist ja kein Bild dass wir uns
ausdenken sondern das sind einfach die
Fragmente die wir aus Europa aus der
Ukraine bekommen die dieses Bild
zusammensetzen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
führung bedeutet ein klares Ziel zu
formulieren und das muss sein Russland
darf diesen Krieg nicht militärisch
gewinnen Russland darf in der Ukraine
militärisch nicht erfolgreich sein und
diesem Ziel müssen wir unser Handeln
entsprechend ausrichten und das bedeutet
auch dass wir in der Lage ankommen dass
wir nicht mit unserer neuen bis 16 Uhr
Bürokratie hier unterwegs sein können
das heißt konkret dass wir akzeptieren
dass dieser Krieg nicht in Wochen vorbei
sein wird das heißt konkret das auch
schwere Waffen einbezogen werden müssen
es ist unverständlich dass diese bisher
immer von den Listen gestrichen worden
sind und Verantwortung zwischen
Verteidigungsministerium und Kanzleramt
hin und her geschoben wird
dem Ziel alles unterordnen heißt konkret
dass wir auch schwere Waffen westlicher
Bauart brauchen werden um meine Damen
und Herren es ist eine Entscheidung der
Freunde in der Ukraine ob sie diese
personelle und zeitliche Investition
tätigen wollen und keine Frage von uns
wir müssen uns darüber wenig Gedanken
machen alles dem Ziel das Russland nicht
erfolgreich ist unterordnen heißt auch
konkret dass es nicht Wochen dauern kann
bis Genehmigungen erteilt werden für
Gerät welches in unserer
Rüstungsindustrie verfügbar ist und
sofort geliefert werden kann und es ist
auch wichtig das heißt konkret dass wir
das Signal geben dass die internationale
Gemeinschaft Waffen Munition
Betriebsstoffe liefert solange es nötig
ist
meine Damen und Herren
Butscher war Aussicht von Wladimir Putin
nur der Anfang er will die Ukraine
auslöschen er will Ukraine vernichten
Putin hat das öffentlich gesagt wir
müssen ihm beim Wort nehmen ich rufe
dazu auf dass wir wirklich alles tun um
das zu verhindern ich rufe die
Bundesregierung auf legen Sie das Zögern
ab gehen sie beherzt voran dann haben
Sie auch unsere Unterstützung herzlichen
Dank
Thomas Erne fordert hier ein beherztes
vorangehen und während hier diese
Debatte läuft hat die USA neue
Sanktionen gegen Russland angekündigt
unter anderem sollen zwei große
russische Banken und die erwachsenen
Kindern das russischen Präsidenten
Wladimir Putin von diesen Strafmaßnahmen
betroffen sein
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren liebe DemokratInnen und
Demokraten und andere als Mutter und als
menschenrechtspolitikerin schnürt es mir
die Kehle zu wenn ich die Bilder der
Ermordeten Zivilistinnen in Butcher C
die Berichte über hunderte toter in den
Kever Vorstädten Butcher und gostemmen
und der Fund von zahlreichen leichenen
Massengräbern all das weist verweiser
von grausames Massaker an der
Zivilbevölkerung Frauen Kinder Alter
hingerichtet
die ukrainische Abgeordnete Ina source
berichtet das auch Leichname von Kindern
mit verbundenen Händen gefunden wurden
Sergej ein Bestatter aus Butscher
erzählt in der Tat dass sie über 300
Leichen geborgen hätten ca 30% sein
Frauen und Kinder gewesen vielen waren
die Hände auf den Rücken
zusammengebunden ist ist und bleibt in
erträglich das sind keine Bilder aus der
Vergangenheit das geschieht heute
vielleicht sogar jetzt während wir hier
über diese Gräueltaten debattieren
ebenso schlimm finde ich es dass es auch
bei uns in Deutschland Menschen gibt die
diese Gräueltaten als Inszenierung der
ukrainischen Regierung abstreiten und
das Ausmaß der Unmenschlichkeit in Frage
stellen
sie gehen demonstrieren auf unsere
Straßen und nutzen das
Demonstrationsrecht aus was in Russland
verwehrt wird
es gibt leider auch Mandatsträger und
Kandidierende die dieses in Zweifels
Stellen nicht umsonst gucke ich in ihre
Richtung und ich würde Sie bitten lieber
afd-fraktion ihren Dresdner
OB-Kandidaten man ein bisschen zu zügeln
danke
die
Propaganda-Maschinerie des cremets
scheint nämlich auch hier zu verfangen
dabei müsste man sich nur auf der
offiziellen Nachrichten Webseite der
russischen Regierung umschauen die
Russische Föderation macht keinen Hehl
daraus worum es ihnen wirklich geht ich
zitiere Ukrainer müssen so zahlreich wie
möglich getötet werden nicht nur die
Eliten die meisten Menschen sind
schuldig sie sind passive Nazis
zynischer geht es wirklich kaum noch ein
friedliches prosperierendes Land wie die
Ukraine das eine Atomwaffen 94 an
Russland abgegeben hat dass die
Grundwerte der EU anerkennt ein Land in
dem Überlebende der
nationalsozialistischen
Vernichtungslager durch russischen
raketenbeschluss ermordet werden ein
Land mit einem jüdischen Präsidenten an
seiner Spitze und ein Land in dem seit
30 Jahren die rechtsradikalen Parteien
und Kräfte dort scheitern rechtsextreme
meist an der 5% der Hürde hier leider
nicht ein solches Land verdient nicht
nur unsere Solidarität sondern es hat
auch seinen Platz in Europa in der
Europäischen Union verdient in Freiheit
und an unserer Seite
die Fach die tats vom 4 April berichtet
von einem Grab das in einem Nachbardorf
von Butcher gefunden wurde in diesem
Grab liegen zwei Frauen und vier Männer
alle mit Schüssen in den Hinterkopf
exekutiert das ist die Familie der
dorf-vorsteherin Olgas zu Schenkung Sie
und Ihre Familie sind seit dem 23 März
verschwunden sie war eine
Kommunalpolitikerin wie viele von uns ja
auch die sich dem Militär nicht beugen
wollte und dafür wurden sie und ihre
Familie entführt und menschenverachtend
liquidiert die Bürgermeisterin gehörte
zur Funktion Elite eines Landes eines
Landes dem Präsident Putin die
Existenzberechtigung wiederholt
abgesprochen hat die Opfer von Butcher
sind nicht den Entgleisungen einzeln
dazuzurechnen die durch den
traumatischen Erfahrungen und des
Grauens des Krieges durchdrehen nein sie
sind die Taten eines
mordenden gezielt morgenden sehr Apparat
der vom Kreml aus befehligt und befeuert
wird wir wissen nun von Wutscher wie
viele Botschaft es tatsächlich sind in
denen das russische Militär
Zivilistinnen ermordet verschleppt und
gefoltert hat das wissen wir zu diesem
Zeitpunkt noch nicht sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren ich fordere analog zur un-
menschenrechtskommissarin Michelle
bacilet ein unabhängige Untersuchung in
der Ukraine dazu gehört eine umfassende
Beweissicherung und Exhumierung und
Identifizierung aller Leichenfunde
seht wird die Entschlossenheit der
internationalen Justiz ernten wer
Kriegsverbrechen legitimiert und
relativiert macht sich mitschuldig bis
es jedoch soweit ist bis alles
aufgeklärt ist müssen wir diesen
politischen und wirtschaftlichen Druck
auf Putin maximal verstärken bei
Kriegsverbrechen gibt es nicht mehr
allzu viel zu diskutieren mit zwei
Zeilen von danger dan möchte ich
schließen Faschisten hören niemals auf
Faschisten zu sein man diskutiert mit
ihnen nicht das hat die Geschichte
gezeigt nicht diskutieren sanktionieren
danke dass Sie das tun die war
Bundeskanzler Liebe Bundesregierung
danke
[Applaus]
damit beenden wir die Aktuelle Stunde
und führen fahren in unserer
tagesordnungs fort
wir kommen zum
Tagesordnungspunkt
3 der vereinbarten Debatte zum 30
jahrestag des Kriegsbeginn in
Bosnien-Herzegowina also wir bleiben bei
der Außenpolitik denn vor 30 Jahren kam
es ja zu den Kriegen nach Zerfall des
vielvölkerstadts Jugoslawien und im
April 1992 ging dann der Krieg im
heutigen Bosnien-Herzegowina los mit der
Belagerung der Hauptstadt Sarajevo
endete erst im November
1995 mit der Unterzeichnung des
Abkommens von Dayton aber auch dieser
Frieden ist immer noch brüchig und
gerade in den letzten Tagen auch in den
letzten Wochen sieht man immer wieder
das ist zu Spannungen kommt das ist zu
Abspaltung
Motivationen kommt und auch das
beschäftigt hier die Bundesregierung in
Deutschland wie man es schaffen kann den
Balkan auch dort näher an die EU
heranzubringen
da wird nun wahrscheinlich die erste
Rednerin noch mal genauer darauf
eingehen anal Lührmann ist
Staatsministerin für Europa und Klima im
Auswärtigen Amt und die Außenministerin
Anna-Lena baerbock war gerade Anfang
März in eben Balkan unter anderem mit
dem Sonderbeauftragten der
Bundesregierung für den Westbalkan auch
Manuel Sarrazin
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
in diesen Tagen sind wir alle geschockt
von den Bildern aus Butcher und anderen
ukrainischen Dörfern
Dörfern und Städten
wir sind geschockt von der Brutalität
des russischen Angriffskrieges
unschuldige Zivilisten sind bestialisch
ermordet worden gezielt erschossen beim
Versuch vom Bomben zu fliehen das sind
grausame Kriegsverbrechen die wir aus
Schärfste verurteilen
Erinnerung an den furchtbaren Völkermord
von trebrenitzer werden wach
heute erinnern wir an den Kriegsbeginn
in Bosnien und Herzegowina vor 30 Jahren
in diesem schrecklichen Krieg von
1992 bis 1995 haben über 100.000
Menschen ihr Leben verloren und weit
mehr als zwei Millionen sind vertrieben
worden
zwar konnte das Friedensabkommen von
Daten den Krieg beenden aber wir sehen
dass die ethnischen Spaltung des Landes
noch immer den Alltag prägt die Politik
dominiert und die Fortschritte blockiert
das Land braucht weiter unsere
Aufmerksamkeit und unsere Unterstützung
denn statt aktiver Aufarbeitung und
Versöhnungsarbeit sind heute wieder
nationalistische und hetzerische
Rhetorik Teil des politischen Diskurses
leider gehören dazu auch die Leuten von
Kriegsverbrechen und Genozid bis hin zu
ihrer Verherrlichung
zusätzlich hat das Parlament der
bosnisch-serbischen Entität Republica
konkrete rechtliche Schritte eingeleitet
die Region weiter vom Gesamtstaat
abzuspalten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das sind
Angriffe auf den einheitlichen Staat
Bosnien und Herzegowina das sind
Angriffe auf Frieden und Stabilität im
westlichen Balkan das sind Angriffe auf
ganz Europa
[Applaus]
ein solch destruktives Verhalten darf
nicht ohne Konsequenzen bleiben die
Bundesregierung hat darauf reagiert so
halten wir die bilaterale Unterstützung
für die republikas zurück und setzen uns
bei der EU und mit anderen gebäuern für
die gezielte konditionalisierung von
Hilfen ein wir halten auch Sanktionen
gegen diejenigen die diesen destruktiven
sezessionskurs vorantreiben für nötig
allen voran midorat dudik
wir begrüßen zu dem ausdrücklich die
Aktivierung der Reserve der europäischen
Schutztruppe euphor Altea diese erfüllt
eine sehr wichtige stabilisierende
Funktion deshalb prüfen wir auch aktuell
innerhalb der Bundesregierung Optionen
für eine erneute Beteiligung der
Bundeswehr an dieser Operation damit
könnten wir in diesem sehr kritischen
Moment für das Land ein klares Zeichen
setzen wir stehen entschlossen an eurer
Seite für Frieden und für Stabilität und
über einen möglichst Mandat werden wir
natürlich hier im Deutschen Bundestag
gründlich und ausführlich beraten
die Bundesministerin Anna-Lena baerbock
hat mit ihrem Besuch in Sarajevo in
Pristina und in Belgrad Anfang März ein
klares Zeichen gesetzt der westliche
Balkan ist ein Schwerpunkt der Arbeit
der Bundesregierung auch die Ernennung
des neuen
Sonderbeauftragten für die Länder des
westlichen Balkans Manuel Sarrazin
unterstreicht die Bedeutung die wir
dieser Region beimessen
es ist wichtig dass wir vor Ort Präsenz
zeigen und das gilt auch für die
Mitglieder dieses Hauses möchte sie also
ausdrücklich zu reisen ermuntern wichtig
ist auch unsere volle Unterstützung für
den Hohen Repräsentanten Christian
Schmidt
und gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern
unterstützen wir aktiv den Weg Bosnien
und Herzegowinas in die Europäische
Union
etwa mit Projekten zur Stärkung der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit aber der
Reformprozess kommt leider viel zu
langsam voran meine Damen und Herren
klar ist dass es ohne Reformen auch
keinen EU-Kandidatenstatus geben kann
hier stehen die politischen Akteure vor
Ort in der Pflicht eine Pflicht nicht
nur der EU gegenüber sondern vor allen
Dingen den Menschen in ihrem Land
und dieser Verantwortung müssen die
Parteien auch bei der verfassungs- und
Wahlrechtsreform nachkommen
hier müssen Diskriminierungen beseitigt
werden und wichtige Empfehlungen der
OSZE zur Verhinderung von
Wahlmanipulation umgesetzt werden bei
all dem gilt aber die Reform dürfen die
ethnische Spaltung im Land nicht weiter
vertiefen
ebenso klar ist wenn eine Einigung auf
die Wahlrechtsreform nicht gelingt die
Wahlen müssen wie geplant im Oktober
stattfinden
Versuche
versuche die Wahlen zu verschieben oder
zu boykottieren würden nur die
innenpolitischen Spannungen im Land
verschärfen und das Land weiter
zurückwerfen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Bosse und Herzegowina steht ohne Zweifel
vor sehr großen Herausforderungen das
heutige Gedenken an den Kriegsbeginn
erinnern uns aber auch an die weite
Strecke die das Land in den letzten 30
Jahren Richtung EU zurückgelegt hat
ich bin daher überzeugt eine
demokratische eine friedliche Zukunft in
Bosnien-Herzegowina ist möglich eine
Zukunft in der Europäischen Union dafür
müssen aber alle politisch
Verantwortlichen vor Ort wirklich klar
den Kurs Richtung dieses Zieles setzen
und dabei wird die Bundesregierung das
Land um seine Menschen nach Kräften
unterstützen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Anna Löhrmann hat hier den ersten
Redebeitrag zur vereinbarten Debatte
da gelegt und auf sie folgt nun Peter
Beyer
cdu/csu-fraktion Mitglied im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss und der wander 19
Legislaturperiode Koordinator für die
transatlantische Zusammenarbeit der
Bundesregierung Herren verehrte
Kolleginnen
abrill heute vor 30 Jahren wir gedenken
heute dem Kriegsbeginn in
Bosnien-Herzegowina ich möchte aber auch
noch mal ein paar Jahrzehnte zurückgehen
nämlich in den April 1941
im April 1941 also vor 81 Jahren hat
Nazi Deutschland Bosnien und Herzegowina
überfallen
und
Nazideutschland die Wehrmacht hat zu
diesem Zeitpunkt auch sarajev überfallen
auch das soll heute nicht vergessen
werden
meine Damen und Herren und deswegen ist
es falsch wenn wir gerade in diesen
Wochen und Tagen immer wieder hören
dass seit dem Ende des Zweiten
Weltkrieges ist keinen Krieg auf
europäischen Boden gegeben hat denn
dieser Krieg vor 30 Jahren der vor 30
Jahren in Bosnien-Herzegowina begonnen
hat ist heute noch für die Menschen in
bosnien-
dieser Krieg war damals mit vielen
Gräueltaten verbunden es war ein Genozid
der nicht vergessen ist Insa es waren
systematische Internierungslager es
würde wurden systematisch Massen
Vergewaltigungen als Bestandteil eines
kriegsverbrecherischen Systems
eingesetzt das darf alles nicht
vergessen werden meine Damen und Herren
und wenn wir heute schauen in die
Realität der Bevölkerung bosnien-
so durchlebt dieses Land die größte
Kriege Krise nach Beendigung dieses
Kriegs von vor 30 Jahren Frau
Staatsministerin dührmann hat es gerade
schon angesprochen es sind
separationsbestrebungen der re:publica
sirbska der Präsident neodad doddick
wird befeuert wird unterstützt aus
Moskau aus dem Kreml von Russland bei
diesen
separationsbestrebungen und erst in
wenigen Wochen im Anfang Mai treten die
ersten Gesetze in Kraft die die ersten
Schritte heraus sein sollen für die bei
der Herauslösung der re:publica aus dem
gesamtstaaten Gefüge meine Damen und
Herren
und ich will auch noch daran erinnern
dass es für die Menschen in
Bosnien-Herzegowina heute neben dem
politischen Bedrohungen neben der
politischen Realität auch noch eine
Gefährdung gibt die aus der Zeit des
Krieges von vor 30 Jahren herholt immer
noch 7.000 Menschen sind vermisst deren
Schicksal deren verbleibt nicht
aufgeklärt ist Bosnien Herzegowina gilt
als das eines der meist vermieten Länder
dieser Welt mit
180.000 Landminen immer noch ein
Waldspaziergang ist daher wirklich eine
gefährliche Sache
und wenn wir gerade im Kontext dieses
Angriffs Krieges Russland gegen die
Ukraine in diesen Wochen und Tagen hören
müssen dass der russische Botschafter in
Sarajevo in Bezug auf einen potenziellen
möglichen NATO-Mitgliedschaft des Landes
was uns Herbst vorzukommen das sich für
nehmen lässt in den Medien des Landes es
ist eine Sache wir mischen uns da nicht
ein wir haben das nicht zu kommentieren
wenn das Land selbst eine interne
Entscheidung trifft er dann aber im
nächstensatz direkt anschließt das ist
eine andere Sache sei wie die Reaktion
Moskaus darauf ist dann ist das eine
unverhohlene Drohung gegen die
Bevölkerung bosnien-herzegowin aus
meiner Damen und Herren
2016 so lange ist es schon her im Jahre
2016 hat Bosnien ins Herzegowina einen
Antrag auf EU-Mitgliedschaft gestellt
seitdem ist was geschehen sehr wenig
immer noch ist Bosnien Herzegowina nur
potenzieller Kandidat das ist nicht gut
für das Land für die Menschen das ist
nicht gut für die Europäische Union so
wie sie heute da steht das ist deswegen
nicht gut weil immer mehr Kräfte
in Bosnien-Herzegowina und ich schließe
an in der gesamten des Balkanregion in
den gesamten sechs Staaten des
westlichen Balkans ein Einfluss gewinnen
die ist nicht gut meinen mit Demokratie
mit Rechtsstaatlichkeit mit freier
Meinungsäußerung für die neue Länder
hier gar nicht namentlich benennen sie
sind bekannt und deswegen muss es gerade
jetzt für uns eine Lehre sein
Bosnien-Herzegowina und die Staaten des
westlichen Balkans eine
beschleunigte europäische Perspektive im
Chance der Europäischen Union nicht nur
geographisch sondern auch als Mitglied
zu geben deswegen muss dieser Prozess
deutlich schneller erfolgen meine Damen
und Herren
es ist gut dass wir jetzt gesehen haben
dass fünf Kompanien 500 Mannstärke bei
der Operation altera hinzugekommen sind
es ist gut dass der Hohe Repräsentant
Christian Schmidt mit der
Außenministerin bei deren Besuch den
Staatsministerin Lührmann angesprochen
hat darüber gesprochen hat dass euphor
ein eigenes deutsches Mandat bekommt
dass es verstärkt wird und zum Schluss
komme dann zum Schluss frau Präsidentin
das ist ein richtiger Weg der auch die
Unterstützung meiner Fraktion erfahren
wird bloß ich meine an dieses Mandat
haben wir noch nicht gesehen und ich
rege an dass es nicht nur punktuell
sondern im gesamten Land Boss und Haut
segowina eine ein Mandat erhält um hier
operieren zu können es tut not denn wir
brauchen Stabilität im Herzen Europas
Bosnien-Herzegowina gehört in die
Europäische Union herzlichen Dank
Peter Beyer spricht hier zum Schluss
auch noch die Rückkehr der Bundeswehr in
den
Balkanland an das ist eine Diskussion
die wird hier noch geführt wird werden
die Bundeswehr ist ja eine
Parlamentsarmee gerade deswegen muss für
jedem Auslandseinsatz des Parlaments
auch der Bundestag darüber entscheiden
Svenja Schulze Bundesministerin
Bundesministerin für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung spricht
jetzt als nächstes
der Krieg des russischen Präsidenten
Putin gegen die Ukraine ist der erste
Angriffskrieg in Europa gegen ein
anderes Land seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
es ist aber nicht der erste Krieg auf
europäischen Boden seit 1945 bereits
1991 hatten bittere Kriege im
zerfallenen Jugoslawien begonnen erst in
Slowenien dann in Kroatien und heute vor
30 Jahren
begann ein Krieg im Herzen des
multiätischen Balkans im der
erbauungslose Krieg in
Bosnien-Herzegowina und das ist gut dass
wir heute hier im Bundestag darin
erinnern dieser Krieg hat fast vier
Jahre gewütet er hat mehr als 100.000
Menschen das Leben gekostet über 20.000
Frauen mussten systematischer
Massenvergewaltigungen erleiden über
zwei Millionen Menschen wurden
vertrieben das Massaker von rebenitzka
ein schweres so schwerste
Kriegsverbrechen in Europa seit dem Ende
des Zweiten Weltkrieges wurde Jahre
später vom Internationalen Gerichtshof
als Völkermord bewertet und Ende 1995
konnten mit dem datenabkommen dieser
grausame Krieg beendet und eine fragile
eine fragile Balance in einem
komplizierten staatsgeb geschaffen
werden heute 30 Jahre später blicken wir
wieder auf bedrohliche Entwicklungen in
Bosnien-Herzegowina im dezember
2021 hat das Regionalparlament der
republikas beschlossen alle alle seit
1995 vollzogenen Kompetenz Übertragung
des Gesamtstaates rückgängig zu machen
und innerhalb von sechs Monaten eigene
Institutionen zu schaffen das betrifft
alle Bereiche wie etwa die Streitkräfte
des Justizwesen oder die
Steuerverwaltung und diese
abtrennungsbestrebungen der
repubska die beobachte ich jedenfalls
mit großer Sorge sie gefährden nicht nur
die Stabilität in Bosnien-Herzegowina
gerade in der aktuellen Krisensituation
in der Ukraine drohen hier
Kettenreaktionen auf dem Westbalkan und
auch noch darüber hinaus was bedeutet
das nun für unsere
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit es bedeutet
dass wir jetzt und entschlossen
Konsequenzen ziehen wir sind dabei drei
Punkte ganz besonders wichtig erstens im
Schulterschluss mit der EU-Kommission
müssen Konsequenzen aus diesem
nationalistischen abspaltungskurs
gezogen werden und dafür setzt sich mein
Ministerium ein wir setzen die
Vorbereitung von vier
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen in Höhe von über
100 Millionen Euro in der Republica aus
bis alle diese sessionsbestrebungen
zurückgenommen werden
der zweite Punkt und das ist auch ganz
wichtig Bosnien-Herzegowina muss weiter
unterstützt werden um widerstandsfähiger
gegen Einflussnahmen von außen zu werden
das Land hat trotz der offenen Wunden
aus der Vergangenheit gemeinsam mit
internationalen Partnern erste
Grundlagen für einen funktionierenden
Staat gelegt und es hat dem
Lebensverhältnisse der Menschen deutlich
verbessert die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit die setzt
hier an und wir werden
Bosnien-Herzegowina auch künftig fördern
dabei haben wir auch schon beachtliche
Fortschritte Bundesregierung hat seit
1999 800 über 830 Millionen Euro
bereitgestellt damit es ganz konkret vor
Ort geholfen wurden damit wurden Strom
und Wasserversorgung wieder aufgebaut
Wasserkraftwerke wieder betriebsfähig
gemacht Schulen gebaut Familien bei der
Rückkehr unterstützt ein Steuer ein
katastersystem aufgebaut über
Jugendprojekte wurden Trauma und
Versöhnungsarbeit angeboten und Kunden
die der Krieg geschlagen hat zumindest
für die nächste Generation abzumildern
Deutschland kooperiert in der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit mit
Bosnien-Herzegowina auch zu globalen
Herausforderungen wie der
sozialgerechten Energiewende wir fördern
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen mit
Investitionen in
Beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten und in
energieeffiziente Technologien mit
deutscher Unterstützung wurde 2018 der
erste Windpark des Landes in der Nähe
der Stadt Mosbach finanziert und weitere
Windparks sind in Planung wie wichtig
eine unabhängige Energieversorgung ist
dies sehen wir gerade jetzt und genauso
wie die Regierung in Deutschland sich
darum kümmert Schritt für Schritt aus
der Abhängigkeit von Öl Kohle und Gas
herauszukommen brauchen wir auch für
Länder wie Bosnien-Herzegowina zum
Beispiel ein massiven Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien
und der dritte Punkt der mir wichtig ist
wir unterstützen als Bundesregierung
natürlich den
eu-anährungsprozess auf dem Wahlkampf
auch in der östlichen Nachbarschaft was
sind wir nicht zuletzt den Opfern des
Krieges und den Menschen in der Region
schuldig die sich nach Frieden die sich
nach Sicherheit und Wohlstand sehen die
Europäische Union steht für Frieden für
Versöhnung für Demokratie und
Menschenrechte und diese Werte werden
durch das geschlossene Handeln der EU
geschützt und verteidigt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen russland hat in
den vergangenen 30 Jahren aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen
separatistische Tendenzen in
Partnerländern wie Bosnien-Herzegowina
wie in der Republik Moldau in Georgien
unterstützt dessen sollten wir uns alle
bewusst sein und allen Tendenzen einer
politischen einer wirtschaftlichen
Destabilisierung in Europa konsequent
entgegentreten herzlichen Dank
soweit die Bundesministerin für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung und auch die
bosnisch-herzegowinische Diplomaten und
Botschafterin ist hier in dieser Debatte
dabei verfolgt die Debatte von der
Zuschauer Tribüne außer 2019 ist die
Botschafterin in Deutschland
Jadranka vimbo
Joachim wudrak spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin Werte Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren
vor dem Hintergrund des Krieges in der
Ukraine und den offensichtlichen
Kriegsverbrechen fällt es durchaus
schwer über die Kriege der 90er Jahre im
ehemaligen Jugoslawien zu sprechen
auch damals galt und ich ergänze hier
das Zitat von Herrn Trittin von
Clausewitz auch damals galt wenn
geschossen wird statt zu reden haben
Politik und Diplomatie versagt
und dass dieses Versagen einen hohen
einen sehr hohen Preis kostet müssen wir
in diesen Tagen schmerzlich als
Zuschauer einer fürchterlichen Tragödie
in der Ukraine ertragen der Zerfall der
Bundesrepublik Jugoslawien führte wie
schon gehört am 5 märz 1992 zu Erklärung
der Unabhängigkeit der Republik Bosnien
und Herzegowina bereits vorher hatten
Slowenien und Kroatien ihre
Unabhängigkeit erklärt die von
Deutschland und anderen schnell
anerkannt wurde
in Slowenien griff die jugoslawische
Armee ein wurde jedoch zurückgeschlagen
aufgrund der weitgehend ethnischen
Homogenität der Bevölkerung in Slowenien
kam es hier zu keinen inneren Kämpfen
in Bosnien dagegen wie zuvor schon in
Kroatien brachen unmittelbar nach der
Unabhängigkeitserklärung
schwere Unruhen aus diese führten
schließlich in einen grausamen
Bürgerkrieg auch mit wechselnden
Beteiligungen der Volksgruppen der
Serben Kroaten und Bosnien schwerste
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und
Kriegsverbrechen wie ethnische
Säuberungen und Massaker an der
Zivilbevölkerung fanden auf allen Seiten
statt
das Massaker von sribeniza mit ca 8.000
ermordeten wurde gerichtlich als Genozid
an den Bosniaken eingestuft
dem Verfahren vorausgegangen war eine
intensive Untersuchung dieses
Massenmordes durch eine internationale
unabhängige Organisation
auch für die Kriegsverbrechen von
Wutscher und anderen Orten in der
Ukraine die in diesen Tagen uns und die
Welt bewegen ist eine solche unabhängige
Untersuchung der einzige Weg um jenseits
der kriegspopaganda Klarheit über die
Verantwortlichkeiten zu erlangen
der Krieg in Bosnien endete schließlich
nach Robusta Intervention der NATO aus
der Luft im Dezember 1995 mit dem
Abkommen von Dayton die Bilanz der
bosnischen Tragödie mehr als 100.000
Tote mehr als 2 Millionen Flüchtlinge
und Vertriebene davon 350.000 nach
Deutschland
schwer zerstörte Infrastruktur und
wirtschaftlicher Niedergang Millionen
von Minen im Land mit schrecklichen
Folgen für die Bevölkerung
bleibender Hass und tiefes Misstrauen
gegenüber den anderen Volksgruppen
30 Jahre nach der
Unabhängigkeitserklärung sind die Folgen
des Krieges noch präsent die Segregation
der Bevölkerung in den serbischen
kroatischen und
bosniakischen Anteil ist allgegenwärtig
der erwähnte Hass auf die anderen
Volksgruppen wurde leider von
Generationen zu Generationen
weitergegeben
auch viele Schulen spielten und spielen
dabei einen fatale Rolle wie ich selbst
im Laufe eines Einsatzes im gesamten
Bosnien feststellen musste der ehemalige
Hohe Repräsentant christian Schwarz
Schilling kam frustriert zur gleichen
Feststellung
Bosnien-Herzegowina steht immer noch
gemäß datenabkommen unter Überwachung
eines hohen repräsidenten mit
weitreichenden Befugnissen derzeit des
deutschen Christian Schmidt das Abkommen
von Daten das wichtig war um 1995 das
Blutvergießen zu stoppen konserviert
heute einen dysfunktionalen Staat der
aus zwei Entitäten besteht einmal der
Föderation der börsenjacken und
bosnischen Kroaten und zum anderen der
Republik der bosnischen Serben genannt
subscar
seit der Unabhängigkeit Bosniens gibt es
starke Bestrebungen der bosnischen
Serben nach staatlicher Unabhängigkeit
und der bosnischen Kroaten nach einer
dritten Entität
bisher hat die internationale
Gemeinschaft dem nicht nachgegeben
Bosnien-Herzegowina hat 2016 den Antrag
auf Aufnahme in die Europäische Union
gestellt und die EU hat diesen Antrag
auch angenommen allerdings ist der
Beginn der beitragsverhandlungen in
weite Ferne gerückt
der jüngste Bericht der EU spricht in
nahezu allen reformfeldern von keinen
oder nur geringen Fortschritten ja sogar
von Rückschritten
Korruption und organisierte Kriminalität
sind doch nach wie vor indem ich und die
Notwendigkeit wie wir gehört haben der
Verstärkung der eu-operation Altea
spricht Bände
zu Mitglied des Staatspräsidiums
verstärkt derzeit offensichtlich seine
Bestrebungen für eine Unabhängigkeit der
Republik Substrat
er hält dazu Unterstützung aus Serbien
und aus Russland
die Frage wie der Krieg in der Ukraine
nun die Situation in Bosnien und auf dem
gesamten Westbalkan beeinflussen wird
ist offen aber höchst sensitive
ich habe Stimmen vernommen die verlangen
Serbien den Status eu-kandidat
abzuerkennen weil Serbien sich zum Krieg
gegen die Ukraine gegen die Ukraine
gegenüber Russland nicht kritisch genug
einlässt
diese Aberkennung wäre fatal und der
völlig falsche Weg
die Bundesregierung und die EU sind
daher dringend aufgerufen durch eine
langfristige Strategie und eine kluge
Politik für den gesamten Westbalkan die
legitimen Interessen aller Beteiligten
zu berücksichtigen ja auch die Serbiens
der serbischen Bevölkerung Bosniens und
des Kosovo
der Schlüssel für ein friedliches
Zusammenleben auf dem Westbalkan liegt
nämlich auch in Belgrad
Werte Kollegen es gilt gerade jetzt
durch kluge Politik und Diplomatie zu
verhindern dass in der derzeitigen
hochemotionalen Lage in Bosnien und im
Kosovo einseitige Entscheidungen zur
Sezession getroffen werden
es muss also unser dringendes Interesse
sein ein dadurch mögliches
übergreifendes Konflikts von der Ukraine
auf den Westbalkan zu verhindern
wie gesagt der Schlüssel dazu liegt in
Belgrad dazu muss miteinander geredet
werden und es müssen gangbare
Kompromisse gefunden werden es gibt
keinen anderen Weg zur Erhaltung des
Friedens in Bosnien Herzegowina und auf
dem Westbalkan ich bedanke mich für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Joachim wundrack war das für die
afd-fraktion er ist für seine Fraktion
auch Mitglied im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
und nächster Redner ist Jens Beeck für
die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
hochverehrte frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen Exzellenz
schön dass sie heute bei uns sind und
ich hoffe sie nehmen aus dieser Debatte
mit dass wir uns hier sehr ernsthaft mit
ihrer Geschichte aber auch mit ihren
aktuellen Herausforderungen befassen und
dass sie Deutschland an ihrer Seite
wissen auf dem Weg noch mehr in unsere
Gemeinschaft
ich dass ich in dieser Woche zum 30 Mal
der Beginn des Bosnienkrieges jährt ist
alleine zusammen mit dem Gedenken an das
Massaker von striplinica hinreichender
Anlass für diese Debatte
allerdings kommt man in diesem Tag und
der Kollege Beyer der auch schon darauf
hingewiesen nicht umhin
Parallelen zu den aktuellen Ereignissen
unserem letzten Tagesordnungspunkt hier
im Plenum zu ziehen zu den parallelen
des angriffskriegs Russland gegen die
Ukraine und auch das ist schon genannt
worden vor zwei Wochen ist der
Botschafter Russlands im
Bosnien-Herzegowina gefragt worden ob
denn aus den Herzegowina sich eigentlich
der NATO oder der EU anschließen könne
und die Antwort war ja das entscheidet
jeder für sich selbst aber wie wir
reagieren sehr jemand im Grunde derzeit
auch bei Russland das ist ja Kollege
Beyer natürlich eine Drohung
gegen die Menschen in
Bosnien-Herzegowina es ist auch eine
Drohung gegen unsere westliche
Weltordnung und gegen die
Eigenständigkeit in Souveränität jede
Staates und dem werden wir uns in aller
Härte entgegenstehen
wir beobachten diese dreisten und
unverhohlenen Methoden Russlands im
Balkan schon länger
wir wissen um die Verwicklung Russlands
2018 beim namensreferendum in
nordmazedonien wir wissen um
Verwicklungen beim Putschversuch in
Montenegro 2016 und wir werden dies auch
in der aktuellen Situation nicht länger
hinnehmen sondern aktiv entgegenarbeiten
Bossi und Herzegowina hat eine
glaubhafte Perspektive in der
Europäischen Union und auch in der NATO
verdient setzt wichtige Voraussetzungen
des membership Action plant um und hat
auch bei Defender europe21 gerade erst
bewiesen dass die Zusammenarbeit mit der
NATO hervorragend funktioniert es geht
Russland vor allem darum die
EU-Integration zu verhindern aber diese
Aktionen werden den Weg
Bosnien-Herzegowinas noch stärker in die
Europäische Gemeinschaft nur verzögern
sie werden sie nicht aufhalten können
dafür werden wir hier in diesem Hause
nach unseren Kräften mit sorgen
[Applaus]
im übrigen auch das richtige Ziel für
die Menschen in ihrem Landfrau
Botschafterin denn das muss man auch in
diesen Zeiten immer wieder
unterstreichen sie streben zu Recht nach
Souveränität nach Freiheit nach
Menschenrechten nach Demokratie und das
ist genau das das Glück für den
Einzelnen auch in einem souveränen Staat
das Putin nicht bieten kann er kann
immer nur bieten Vorteile für einzelne
Autokraten und leider das ist
angesprochen worden ist mit miloradodik
auch in ihrem aktuellen Dreier
präsidialgremium ein solcher vorhanden
wir stehen an ihrer Seite nicht an
seiner um das auch deutlich zu sagen und
wenn dieser herodik behauptet gegenüber
der Außenministerin beerbock in den
angesprochenen
besuchen dass er an der Sezession des
Landes nicht arbeite gleichzeitig aber
die illegalen Strukturen aufbaut dann
bin ich Ihnen Frau Schulze sehr dankbar
dass sie daraus die richtigen
Konsequenzen ziehen und dass sie sehr
deutlich machen an welcher Stelle diese
Bundesregierung an welcher Stelle
Deutschland seine Prioritäten setzt dass
wir diejenigen unterstützen auf
Menschenrechte auf Zusammenarbeit auf
freiheitliche Werte und Demokratie
stehen und dass diejenigen das gehört
dann auch dazu die sich davon abwenden
unsere Unterstützung jedenfalls in dem
Maße wie früher nicht mehr bekommen
westliche Staatengemeinschaften hier
noch die große Gemeinschaft derjenigen
die Demokratie Freiheit und
Menschenrechte in der Welt auf der Basis
von Respekt und Zusammenarbeit auf der
Basis der regelbasierten Ordnung der
Vereinten Nationen der auch wir uns
verschrieben haben darf sich nicht
ausbremsen lassen von diesen einzelnen
Aktionen die allerdings in der Welt
immer stärker um sich greifen deswegen
ist es unsere Aufgabe in diesen Zeiten
diejenigen zusammenzuführen die unsere
Werte teilen die unsere Außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen Entscheidungen
ebenfalls teilen und sich auch dem
entgegenzustellen die das ausdrücklich
nicht tun das ist die Kehrseite dieser
Medaille als internationaler
Gemeinschaft müssen wir viel mehr das
hat Christian Schmidt in seinen Brief an
uns alle deutlich gemacht Bosnien
Herzegowina weiter unterstützen der Weg
der zu gehen ist ist noch ein Stück und
wir müssen auch den hohen Vertreter
selbst bei seinen Aufgaben so handfest
unterstützen wie er sich das wünscht
aber wir sind uns glaube ich in diesem
Hause einig darin dass wir das tun
wollen und ich bin überzeugt davon dass
das der richtige Weg unseres Handelns im
Balkan unserer unmittelbaren
Nachbarschaft ist zu der wir vielfältige
Wurzeln haben wir stehen an der Seite
der Menschen im Bosnien-Herzegowina weil
sie das wollen und weil wir auch wollen
dass Sie zu uns kommen auf diesem Weg
werden wir gemeinsam weiterarbeiten
vielen Dank
jensweg kündigt hier den weitergang des
Weges der Zusammenkommens EU und
balkantenstaaten an natürlich steht
diese Debatte zum 30 Jahrestags unter
dem Eindruck des Krieges in der Ukraine
und verändert auch den einen oder
anderen
meinungspunkt inwieweit die EU dort sich
annähern soll Gregor Gysi spricht jetzt
für die Linksfraktion
und jetzt beschäftigen wir uns mit
Geschichte
was wir wir ja ausschlussfolgerungen zu
ziehen haben
jugoslawien war das einzige
sozialistische Land in dem Ende der 80er
Anfang der 90er Jahre des 20
Jahrhunderts im Unterschied zu allen
staatssozialistischen Ländern in Europa
nicht die Systemfrage statt dort gab es
immer ein absolutes Reiserecht für die
jugoslawinnen und Jugoslawen waren auch
in der Bundesrepublik beschäftigt es gab
eine frei konvertierbare Währung
tauschbar in Dollar und Deutsche Mark es
gab auch Staatseigentum aber überwiegend
belegschaftseigentum dass sich die
Belegschaften nicht nehmen lassen wollen
außerdem gehört die Jugoslawien nicht
den Warschau Vertrag an
nun sollte aber nach Auffassung auch der
westlichen Regierungen nach dem
Zusammenbruch des Staatssozialismus kein
funktionierendes sozialistisches Land
mitten in Europa bleiben da sich die
Systemfrage nicht stellte wurde die
ethnische veracht Fragen aufgeworfen und
zwar von ihnen aber auch von außen und
Deutschland war das erste Land das so
schnell wie möglich zum Beispiel die
Unabhängigkeit Sloweniens anerkannt
und die Grenzen zwischen den Staaten
wurden von der EU zum Teil so festgelegt
dass Auseinandersetzung bis heute die
Folge sind der deutsche Hochkommissar
für Bosnien Herzegowina Christian
Schmidt hat gerade darauf hingewiesen
und die war so ein bisschen erinnert an
die Teilung von Pakistan und Indien
durch
Großbritannien wo dauerhaft der
kashmail-konflikt organisiert wurde
beim Zerfall Jugoslawiens erinnerte ich
mich an die Worte von Präsident mitteron
der Ende Dezember 1989 zu mir sagte er
fürchte eine Situation wie vor dem
Ersten Weltkrieg und so kam es
entsetzt war ich wie es gelingt konnte
dass Menschen die friedlich in
Jugoslawien über Jahrzehnte zusammen
lebten aufgehetzt und aufgepeitscht sich
gegenseitig totschlucken ich wollte es
nicht wahrhaben musste es aber zur
Kenntnis nehmen und weiß seitdem wie
Menschen weltweit auch manipuliert
werden können die Demokratie muss sie
davor schützen was sie aber nur begrenzt
gelingt durch
interessengeleitete eigene Manipulation
und durch schuld
ein furchtbarer Massenmord an
muslimischen bosnacken durch serbische
täterstadt ich bin froh dass
Verantwortliche vor den Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof gestellt wurden ich
möchte nur dass auch russische aber auch
US-amerikanische Täter vor dem Gericht
zu erscheinen haben die Blauhelme
durften damals nicht eingreifen und es
war ein Fehler des Sicherheitsrates
nicht unverzüglich ein Einsatz zu
beschließen der das morgen gestoppt
hätte
warum haben wir heute die Backe geht es
nur um die Erinnerung nein ich glaube es
wird auch wieder versucht den
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg der NATO
gegen Serbien in irgendeiner Form
moralisch zurechtfertigen aber er war
falsch nach dem Völkerrecht war es ein
verbotener Krieg Jugoslawien hatte
niemand angegriffen und ein
sicherheitsratsbeschluss lag nicht vor
Russland unterhältchen wurde nicht ernst
genommen was übrigens ein wichtiger
Umstand in der Fehlentwicklung des
Verhältnisses zwischen der Nato und
Russland war bis heute ist umstritten ob
im Kosovo wirklich ein Völkermord
stattfand die un-flüchtlingsorganisation
der UNHCR bestritt es aber auch wenn ein
Völkermord stattfand hätte man Mittel
und Wege außerhalb des Krieges finden
können und müssen ihn zu stoppen und die
Abtrennung des Kosovo war letzte nicht
nur die territoriale Integrität Serbiens
sondern auch eine noch heute gültigen
Beschluss des Sicherheit
die gegenwärtige Schlussfolgerung darf
eben nicht in einem Mehr an Kriegen
einer immer höheren Aufrüstung bestehen
sondern muss umgekehrt in einer
Deeskalation in Abrüstung in deutlich
mehr Diplomatie im Interessenausgleich
es geht nicht nur um die eigenen
Interessen sondern auch um die
Interessen des Bögen über und vor allem
in der strikten Einhaltung des
Völkerrechts durch alle Staaten bestehen
mein letzter Satz das geht auch an die
USA wenn ich an den Irak denke das gilt
auch wie gesagt für die NATO es gilt
auch für die Türkei wenn ich an Syrien
und die Kordeln und Kurden denke es gilt
auch für Saudi-Arabien und den Iran wenn
ich an Jemen denke und es gilt in
Wirklichkeit
vor allem für Russland wenn ich an den
entsetzlichen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
denke
Debatte ist Boris Boris Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin euer
Exzellenz Frau Botschafterin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute vor 30
Jahren begann in Bosnien-Herzegowina ein
Krieg schrecklicher Krieg und uns
erreichten damals für heute entsetzliche
Bilder von grausamen Verbrechen es ist
unsere Aufgabe nicht wegzuschauen
sondern hinzuschauen und die Täter und
die Verantwortlichen für diese
Verbrechen vor Gericht zu stellen dafür
sind wir heute hier
wenn ich persönlich an den
kriegsbedingten denke dann denke ich
daran
meist sofort an Sarajevo die Stadt die
fast vier Jahre lang belagert wurde und
beschossen wurde von den Hügeln drumrum
die Stadt über die mein Vater eins sagen
sie ist die schönste auf dem Balkan weil
einige tausend Pioniere sie aufgehübscht
hatten für die Olympiade ich denke
natürlich an wutschko das kleine
Maskottchen das die Spiele mit dem
Heulen begann ich war zehn Jahre alt
sportbegeistert für uns waren das Spiele
die uns stolz machten auf den Balkan das
waren unsere Spiele sie werden sich
vermutlich an Kati Witt und Jens
Weißflog erinnern ich denke an das
Finale Russland Tschechien im Eishockey
und keine zehn Jahre später wurde in
dieser gleichen Stadt wurden in dieser
gleichen Stadt 380.000 Menschen
eingeschlossen starben in den folgenden
dreieinhalb Jahren 10.000 Menschen auf
Straßen an Orten auf Marktplätzen
sniper-ally die Allee der Scharfschützen
das ist gerade heute eine Erinnerung die
uns mahnen muss noch im März 1992 haben
10.000 Menschen sich zusammengefunden um
für den Frieden zu demonstrieren noch
heute erinnert das Projekt Xetra Tage
der Hoffnung daran dass im ganzen Land
viele hunderttausend Menschen auf
Konzerten für den Frieden Frieden Waben
auch dass wir viele Menschen den
Kriegsdienst die Wehrpflicht
verweigerten und sich nicht auf den Weg
in den Krieg machten all das gab es und
all das war scheinbar umsonst denn das
unvorstellbar begann an jedem 6 April
vor 30 Jahren
aber Kriege beginnen nur scheinbar
plötzlich Kriege schleichen sich an
stückchenweise nehmen sich in der
Gesellschaft den Raum vergiften Debatten
mit Hass menschenargumentieren mit
Abneigung mit Vorurteilen und dann ist
es plötzlich da der Überfall der Angriff
scheinbar plötzlich bricht gewaltlos
aber sie hat ein Vorspiel der Krieg in
Bosnien-Herzegowina hat sich angekündigt
und nahm dann doch die furchtbaren
Ausmaße an die wir jetzt schon gehört
haben zahlreiche Kriegsverbrechen sind
dokumentiert 10.000 Fach wurden Frauen
vergewaltigt Menschen getötet über
100.000 tote Zivilisten der Völkermord
von trebrenica es zeigt zu was Hass
Menschen befähigt und das meine Damen
und Herren liebe Frau Botschafterin das
ist der Gegenstand der heutigen Debatte
und daran müssen wir erinnern und machen
dann werden wir heute auf
Bosnien-Herzegowina schauen dann tun wir
das ja mit großer Sorge über das
Friedensabkommen von Dayton gesprochen
worden die Friedensordnung bleibt
zerbrechlich und trotzdem müssen wir uns
fragen was können wir tun und dieses
erinnern die wirksame Aufmerksamkeit und
der Vergangenheit das ist das was wir
auf dem Balkan noch stärker fördern
müssen die Zivilgesellschaft müssen wir
fördern und ich heute sehe dass
Völkermörder wie radkum ladic in den
Geschichtsbüchern wieder als
Kriegshelden gefeiert werden oder an
irgendwelchen Wandbildern gefeiert
werden dann ist es unerträglich für die
Opfer aber auch für mich persönlich
und dann habe ich noch nicht gesprochen
von den vielen hundert wahrscheinlich
1000 Kriegsverbrechern die immer noch
nicht abgeurteilt sind die immer noch
frei rumlaufen in den gleichen Städten
teilweise wie die Opfer meine Damen und
Herren das ist unerträglich und wir
müssen the walkchanders dieses die
Staatsanwaltschaft befähigen diese
Kriegsverbrecher endlich abzuurteilen
die Beweise für die Taten sind ja da im
Land bleibt es ein Tabuthema dass wir
aufbrechen müssen dass wir anpacken
müssen
meine Damen und Herren ich komme zum
Schluss helfen wir der Zivilgesellschaft
in Bosnien-Herzegowina bei ihrer Arbeit
für freie Wahlen für ein Leben in
Frieden und Stabilität bei ihren
Schwierigkeiten mit Umwelt mit Energie
mit den ganzen Herausforderungen damit
wir auch hinterher sagen können wir
haben alles für diesen Frieden getan
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und der nächste Redner der Debatte
Thomas Anders cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen exzellent
von Januar bis April 1996 war ich als
junger Soldat der Bundeswehr in Bosnien
eingesetzt ich war Teil des allerersten
Kontingents jenseits der Sanitäter die
da 1994 auch schon in Somalia waren aber
Teil des allerersten Kontingents das in
einen Auslandseinsatz geschickt wurde
mit der e-formission sollte das
Friedensabkommen von Dayton überwacht
werden und Stabilität nach diesen
schrecklichen kämpfen in Bosnien Einzug
halten die Eindrücke die man da gemacht
hat als junge Mensch waren bestürzen
mitten in Europa
ein Bild der Zerstörung am Ende dieses
Krieges war der Hass dieses Konfliktes
in der Zerstörung in den unzähligen
zerstörten Gebäude in den
Einschusslöchern in den Fassaden der
Häuser deutlich sichtbar und es schien
natürlich in den ersten Tagen irgendwie
unwirklich aber diese massive Zerstörung
das große Leid in Bosnien mitten in
Europa war real bei mir haben sich die
Bilder von unzähligen frischen Gräbern
die eigentlich in jedem Dorf sichtbar
waren eingeprägt dennoch gab es
Zuversicht mit der Unterzeichnung des
Friedensvertrages von Dayton konnte man
annehmen dass die Balkankriege die
letzten Kriege in Europa gewesen sind
und wir auf dem Weg in eine friedliche
Zukunft waren wir müssen aber heute
jedoch feststellen dass wir uns
getäuscht haben es gibt erschreckende
Parallelen zwischen den damaligen aus
Bosnien und heutigen Eindrücken aus der
Ukraine und dabei musste doch gerade die
Lehre aus rebenitz 1995 eigentlich
gewesen sein dass wir als Westen alles
tun um solche Massaker in Zukunft in
Europa zu verhindern
und
ich muss es an dieser Stelle klar sagen
Werte geleitete Außenpolitik muss
natürlich auch heißen Bereitschaft zum
Handeln und politische Führung zu
beweisen das Definieren von Werten
alleine
reicht nicht aus man muss im Ernstfall
auch dazu bereit sein konsequent zu
handeln und das hätte schon die Lektion
aus dem Balkan kriegen sein müssen und
es betrübt mich sehr dass wir sie mit
Blick auf die Ukraine noch nicht
ausreichend verinnerlicht haben dass wir
wieder die die regelmäßig rote Linien
überschritten haben zu lange gewähren
haben lassen
meine Damen und Herren aber Passivität
darf uns in Bezug auf Bosnien nicht ein
weiteres Mal passieren wir haben ein
Land mit einer Blockade der politischen
Klasse wir haben enttäuscht die
Erwartungen auf eine nato- und
EU-Beitritt die republiker serbskar
zündelt und Kriegsverbrecher Putin hat
mit bilorad dodic einen Mann im Staat
Präsidium mit dem er mitten auf dem
Balkan eskalieren kann wir dürfen die
Lage in Bosnien nicht ein weiteres Mal
entgleiten lassen und die Wahlen im
Oktober sind hierbei ganz entscheidend
und ja das ist eine Aufgabe für uns für
uns alle für Deutschland und das hat
Christian Schmidt auch in den letzten
Tagen eingehend beschrieben und ihm
möchte ich ganz herzlich danken für
diesen wichtigen Einsatz für den Frieden
auf dem Balkan es ist gut dass
Deutschland diese verantwortungsvolle
Situation mit
dem erfahrenen diplomatisch erfahrenen
Christian Schmidt besetzen konnte er
muss auf unsere Unterstützung bei seiner
Arbeit für Frieden und Stabilität in
Bosnien zählen können herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
ist hier der nächste Redner Mitglied der
SPD-Mitglied im Ausschuss für
Angelegenheiten der Europäischen Union
und Vorsitzende der
deutsch-südosteuropäischen
Parlamentariergruppe er ist auch in
Kroatien geboren
wenn sie ihre Maske aufsetzen würden
wäre das super
und dann können wir nämlich auch zur zum
nächsten Redner kommen in der Debatte
Joseph johatovic von der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der Tat
jeder Krieg hat eine Vorgeschichte und
der Bosnienkrieg war das Ergebnis des
gesellschaftlichen politischen Versagens
des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens in den 80er
Jahren
werden sich die kommunistische Spitze
des Staates nicht einigen konnten wie
sie in der Visite transition in eine
demokratische Gesellschaft vollziehen
soll und gleichzeitig die Macht erhalten
kann fand eine Anarchie in
Ex-Jugoslawien in brutalster Form statt
die Folge war die alte Machthaber mit
Unterstützung der nationalistischen
Bewegungen unter dem Deckmantel
Selbstbestimmung der völkerkontenden
Regierungswechsel vollziehen und
gleichzeitig ihre korruptes zum Dasein
zum Teil bis heute behalten
der Preis dafür 100.000 Tote und
Millionen Vertriebenen auf allen Seiten
Kollegen und Kollegen das sagt uns dass
uns die Nationalisten in Unterschied zu
Demokraten zwangsläufig früher oder
später in den Krieg treiben
das hat leider auch die internationale
Gemeinschaft seinerzeit nicht sofort
erkannt sondern sie hat vielmehr je nach
Konstellation versucht den Zerfall
Jugoslawiens aufzuhalten oder unter dem
Motto Selbstbestimmung der Völker eine
der Seiten eingenommen die
Selbstbestimmung der Völker kann aber
nur in einer multinationalen
Gesellschaft funktionieren wenn man
gleichzeitig die menschenrechtskarte der
Vereinten Nationen zu Grundlage nimmt
vuco war in Kroatien schon vorher und
später Sarajevo ahmici bogöner bis hin
zum Genozid ins Polo des Grauens in dem
auf allen Seiten ihr Kriegsverbrecher
ihr Unwesen trieb Colo ist denn ein im
Kreise drehender Volkstanz der
westbalkanvölker
nach dem genozidin und in der Ohnmacht
der internationalen Gemeinschaft schloss
man das datenabkommen indem man zwar das
Grauen des Krieges beendete aber dafür
bis heute die korrupte Nationalisten
scheinbar belohnt
deswegen hat in Bosnien-Herzegowina bis
heute keine Seite weiße Handschuhe an
leider oft auch wir selbst nicht
Demokratie statt stapelokratie muss
unsere Devise sein es ist enorm wichtig
dass wir auf der freien demokratischen
Welt und zur demokratischen Grundordnung
in Bosnien-Herzegowina und auch auf dem
Westbalkan bekennen und uns mit den
demokratischen Kräften vor Ort aktiv
solidarisieren wir haben jetzt in diese
demokratische Kräfte beim Aufbau der
demokratischen Grundordnung sowie bei
der Funktionalität demokratischen
Institutionen aktiv unterstützen dabei
reicht es nicht aus allein die zivile
Gesellschaft zu auf die zivile
Gesellschaft zu bauen sondern es muss
auch diesbezüglich die politische
Entschlossenheit und die Geschlossenheit
in der EU vorhanden sein
vor allem aber darf es kein Handel mit
den Nationalisten um unsere
demokratischen Grundwerte gehen denn nur
Demokraten aller Kollegen
vernetzt auf dem Westbalkan kennen den
Frieden sichern und in die EU führen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das allerwichtigste ist jedoch dass wir
unsere Einstellung in unseren Köpfen
verändern
Addis der mich heute dem heute mein
besonderer Dank gilt auch für diese
Stunde hier
aber auch Jasmina ich Luisa Boris Irene
und viele andere Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hier unter uns die aus dem
Westbalkan stammen tun ihr Bestes für
unsere gemeinsame Heimat Deutschland
es sind viele Serben
Kroaten
montenegrina
Albaner unter uns in Deutschland und
Europa die friedlich Schultern Schulter
mit ihren persönlichen Fähigkeiten unser
Land bereichern ohne dass wir wir ihre
nationale Unterschiede kennen warum ist
das in Deutschland und EU möglich und
nicht auf dem Westbalkan meine Antwort
darauf ist es liegt an System und nicht
an den Menschen deshalb müssen wir mit
den Menschen in Bosnien-Herzegowina und
auch den Westbahn
das System ändern das sind wir vielen
Dank für den Demokraten und Demokraten
im Bosnien-Herzegowina und Westbalkan
schuldig denn spätestens Putins Angriff
auf die Ukraine hat uns gezeigt dass die
Sicherheit des westbalgam auch unsere
eigene Sicherheit ist vielen Dank für
Ihre aufmerksam
Renata alt hat in der Debatte zum
Massaker in der Ukraine schon gesprochen
redet jetzt auch hier in der
vereinbarten Debatte zum 30 jahrestag
des Kriegsbeginns in Bosnien-Herzegowina
sehr geehrte Frau
Bundestagspräsidentin sehr geehrte Frau
Botschafterin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vor 30 Jahren begann die
Belagerung der schönen bosnischen
Hauptstadt Sarajevo es war der blutigste
Konflikt in Europa seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg mehr als zwei Millionen
Menschen wurden aus ihrer Heimat
vertrieben an die 100.000 Menschen
verloren ihr Leben
viele von uns auch hier im Deutschen
Bundestag ich persönlich auch waren
Zeitzeugen dieses Krieges ich hätte nie
geglaubt dass es auf dem europäischen
Kontinent noch einmal einen Krieg geben
wird
ein Krieg mitten in Europa darf es nie
mehr geben dafür müssen wir uns alle
mehr denn ihr heute einsetzen
von der Katastrophe die diese Region
erschüttert hat sieht man heute kaum
mehr etwas wenn man in Sarajevo flaniert
dann sieht man verschiedene Kulturen die
in einer Koexistenz nebeneinander
friedlich leben
der Okzident und der Orient reichen sich
hier die Hand doch die Erinnerung an den
Krieg im Bosnien-Herzegowina haben sich
tief in das kollektive Gedächtnis
eingebrannt es sind Erinnerungen an
Belagerung und Völkermord an ein
unvorstellbares Leid das so viele
unschuldige Menschen ereilte es sind
gerade die Bilder die uns heute aus
Butter und Mario Ball erreichen die in
Bosnien diese so traumatischen und
schmerzhaften Erinnerungen wecken
meine Damen und Herren Bosnien und
Herzegowina sieht sich heute mit seiner
schwersten existenziellen Bedrohung der
Nachkriegszeit konfrontiert
hat es gerade angesprochen seit Jahren
schon bevor er in bosnisch serbische
Politiker wie milorado dick mit
nationalistischer Rhetorik die
ethnischen Konfliktlinien im Land in den
vergangenen Monaten haben sie ihre
separatistische Bemühungen verstärkt mit
der Gründung einer eigenen Armee einer
eigenen Steuerbehörde und einem eigenen
Justizapparat für die Republica
die Nachkriegsordnung auseinanderreißen
er wir all das zerstören was in den
letzten 27 Jahren aufgebaut wurde und
das mit großer Unterstützung aus Moskau
aber auch seitens der EU gibt es
versäumlicher die EU hat mit ihrer
Uneinigkeit dem Nationalismus von dortig
Auftritt gegeben sie hat damit Staaten
wie Russland ermöglicht die ressentimas
gegen Brüssel auszunutzen
Putins Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
muss jetzt für uns alle ein Weckruf sein
[Applaus]
die deutsche und europäische
Außenpolitik muss endlich zeigen dass
sie dazu gelernt hat wir dürfen Hinweise
dass Russland die bosnischen Serben
militärisch in Stellung bringt nicht
ignorieren wir brauchen eine klare
europäische Strategie keine Fortsetzung
der Appeasement-Politik der hohe
der Hohe Repräsentant Christian Schmidt
muss dodic rote Linien aufzeigen und
hierfür seine legitim Befugnissen nutzen
jetzt ist meine Damen und Herren die
Zeit an Daten 2 zu verhandeln
und wir müssen die Länder des
westbarkans die sich zu unseren
europäischen Werten bekennen mehr
wirtschaftlich an die EU anbinden wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass der Krämer
mit Hilfe von dodic und seinen Freunden
eine weitere Front der Destabilisierung
auf dem Balkan errichtet die Schrecken
der 19 Jahre dürfen sich nie wiederholen
tonata alt war das für die FDP-Fraktion
auf ihn vor auf sie folgt nun Johannes
Huber erst mittlerweile fraktionslos ist
als Mitglied der AFD hier in den
Bundestag
eingezogen aber am 31 Dezember 21 aus
der Fraktion ausgetreten
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ihre
Exzellenz während wir hier im Ausbruch
und den Folgen des blutigen Krieges in
Bosnien gedenken steht das Land in
diesem Moment am Rande des nächsten
Kriegers der russische Botschafter Igor
Kalle Buch droht unverhohlen mit einem
ukrainischen Szenario falls Bosnien den
europäischen Weg einleiten sollte die
Geschichte wiederholt sich nicht die
Geschichte wiederholen Menschen wie vor
30 Jahren steht auch heute die westliche
Wertegemeinschaft verwirrt daneben und
träumt weiter von einem bosnischen EU
oder nato-beitritts doch das hast den
Nöten des Krieges Alex
zusammengezimmerte Datensystem hat sich
in der Zwischenzeit in etwas Surreales
entwickelt ein kompliziertes System aus
staatlichen kantonalen und
republikanischen Ebenen plus den
district bridge-
und Abgeordnete wie kein anderes Land in
Europa über die Hälfte des BIP geht an
diese Verwaltung die in sich so korrupt
und ineffizient ist dass sie nur noch
mehr Chaos schafft an Chaos dass dieses
schöne stand leider so unlebenswert
macht dass Bosnien weltweit an der
dritten Stelle bei der talentabwanderung
steht wenn jemand die Möglichkeit hat
verlässt man das Land sei denn man kann
nicht oder man ist in das
klientel-netzwerk der Ethno politischen
Clans eingebunden diese Clans können nur
in diesem Biotop existieren und so tun
sie auch nichts um die Situation für die
Menschen im Land zu verbessern im
Gegenteil sie verhindern seit
Jahrzehnten dass Bosnien ein Wahlrecht
bekommt in dem jeder bosnische Bürger
das gleiche Wahlrecht hat unabhängig von
Ethnie und Religion eine der wichtigsten
macht sollen es zudem der Hass gegen die
andere Ethnie also wird versucht das
Prinzip der ethnischen Matrizen in jeden
Aspekt des Lebens zu zwingen diese
bosnische Misere ist nun seit 27 Jahren
schon am Glimmern und es hätte
vielleicht noch 30 Jahre so weitergehen
können doch jetzt stehen wir vor einer
komplett neuen Ausgangssituation nämlich
persönlichen und finanziellen
Verbindungen von Dodik nach Russland
sowie das Auftreten von Putins
Diplomaten auf dem gesamten Balkan
sprechen nicht dafür dass es beim jemand
bleibt ich schließe daher mit einem
Appell an den hohen Christian Schmidt
den mir bosnische Bürger zugetragen
haben persönlich befreien sie so sagen
sie mir die bosnischen Bürger von der
Geiselhaft dieser ethnopolitischen Clans
und nutzen Sie dafür die bonnabifugnisse
ansonsten müssen wir alle zusehen wie
Europa zu einem in einem weiteren Krieg
mit allen bekannten Konsequenzen
hineingezogen werden kann dass uns muss
uns bewusst sein vielen Dank
Johannes Huber war das zwei Minuten
hatte er wie auch der nächste Redner
Philipp Krämer von Bündnis 90 den Grünen
ist Mitglied im
Verteidigungsausschuss und das hier ist
seine erste Rede die er im Deutschen
Bundestag hält bis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
ja frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kollegin Kollegen sehr geehrte
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter der
Anwesenden Delegation vor 30 Jahren im
April 1992 begann mit der Belagerung
sarajebus der sogenannte Bosnienkrieg in
Bosnien und Herzegowina dieser ist da
zwar seit annähernd 20 Jahren beendet
die zugrunde liegenden ethnischen
Spannungen sind jedoch bis heute präsent
die aktuellen Sezessionsbestrebungen der
serbischen Teilautonomie Regionen zeigen
die Gefahr eine erneuten Eskalation in
Bosnien und Herzegowina sie ist
vermutlich größer als noch vor einigen
Jahren und darf auch vor dem Hintergrund
des aktuellen russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine nicht unterschätzt
werden im Gegenteil der Aggressionen und
destabilisierungsversuche Russlands
bestärken all jene die zur Durchsetzung
ihrer politischen Ziele auch vom
militärischen Mitteln nicht
zurückschrecken
vor dem Hintergrund der aktuellen
Entwicklung erscheint es mir wichtig
dass die deutsche Beteiligung an der
Durchsetzung des datenabkommens
mindestens bestehen bleibt besser aber
noch ausgebaut wird das heißt es sollte
ernsthaft geprüft werden ob sich die
Bundeswehr wieder an der euphor-mission
in Bosnien-Herzegowina beteiligt und ob
eine personelle Aufstockung der Mission
insgesamt sinnvoll ist
die internationale Gemeinschaft muss
aber unabhängig davon in der Lage sein
kurzfristig auf einen aufflammenden
Konflikt in dieser Region reagieren zu
können daher ist auch die Aufstockung
der Reserveeinheiten zu befürworten dies
darf aber natürlich nicht zu Lasten dass
Engagements der Bundeswehr bei der
kv-mission im benachbarten Kosovo gehen
bei der kv-version sind bis heute
deutsche Soldatinnen und Soldaten im
Einsatz für deren Friedensdienst ich
mich an dieser Stelle ausdrücklich
bedanken möchte
wir müssen die Sicherheitslage in der
Region im Auge behalten und mit allen
Parteien im Austausch bleiben Europa
kann sich keinen zweiten Krieg leisten
die Menschen auf dem westbalkanheim ein
Leben in Frieden Freiheit und Sicherheit
verdient herzlichen Dank
Philipp Krämer war das für Bündnis 90
die Grünen auf ihn folgten und folgt mal
kleinen der Sprecher für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung der
Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
dieser Krieg war für die Menschen in
Bosnien und Herzegowina eine Katastrophe
das ist durch viele Beiträge hier jetzt
schon deutlich geworden er war eine
Katastrophe für die politische
Entwicklung in der Region und die Bilder
haben sich eingebrannt in unser
Gedächtnis die Bilder von scheppernetzer
die jetzt aktuell durch Butscher wieder
ganz brutal in
zusätzlicher Erinnerung gekommen sind
dieser Krieg ist aber auch
wirtschaftlich eine Katastrophe gewesen
für die Menschen in Bosnien und
Herzegowina und das bis heute auf der
Homepage des Bundesministeriums für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung ist zu lesen über das Land
während des Krieges kamen die Wirtschaft
von Bosnien und Herzegowina fast zum
Erliegen bis heute gehört sie zu den
schwächsten Volkswirtschaften Europas
und leider stimmt es das Leben ist
leider immer noch viel zu stark von den
Kriegsereignissen geprägt und wenn uns
das nicht auch von vielen anderen
Regionen dieser Welt eh klar wäre dann
würde an Bosnien und Herzegowina
besonders beispielhaft deutlich
Sicherheit und Entwicklung bedingen
einander
sind zwei Seiten einer Medaille und ohne
Sicherheit wird es keine Entwicklung
geben und ohne Entwicklung wird es keine
Sicherheit geben
der Mangel an Entwicklung dem Folgen
Vulnerabilität und Unsicherheit Menschen
die zu wenig Perspektive haben die
überhaupt keine Perspektive haben werden
leichte Beute von Scharfmachern auf
verschiedenen Seiten im Land die eh
alles für Fehlentwicklungen halten und
mit Falschinformationen die Leute Ködern
ohne dieses mit besserer Entwicklung
wäre das Geschäft für dodic ganz
sicherlich schwieriger so ist er leicht
erfolgreich und im übrigen Unsicherheit
als Mangel als Ergebnis von mangelnder
Entwicklung wird am Ende nicht nur für
die Menschen in Bosnien und Herzegowina
ein Problem sein sondern auch für uns
überall in Europa Bosnien und
Herzegowina dürfen nicht zu einem
erneuten Pulverfass in im Balkan werden
dass ich dann am Ende natürlich auf ganz
Europa auswirken würde
und der zweite Punkt Mangel an
Sicherheit
verhindert Entwicklung das ist ganz
offensichtlich so bei militärischer
Sicherheit und deswegen ist es auch
richtig dass Peter Beyer eben schon
betont hat dass wenn es zu einem neuen
Mandat der Bundeswehr käme wir das als
Opposition sicherlich sehr positiv und
wohlwollend prüfen werden
aber es ist nicht nur die Frage von
militärischer Sicherheit es ist auch die
Frage von politischer Verlässlichkeit
gut governance
in diesem komplexen Gebilde Bosnien und
Herzegowina und heute viel zu wenig
zumindest zu wenig erfolgreicher Kampf
gegen Korruption und josepiratowitsch
hat das ja auch noch mal ganz deutlich
gemacht auch das ist ein Mangel an
Verlässlichkeit und Sicherheit
Sicherheit aber eigentlich auch in
anderen Bereichen im Bereich Energie und
Infrastruktur Bereiche in denen wir als
Deutschland schon seit einiger Zeit
erhebliche Beiträge leisten
Energieversorgung wird über die KfW
finanziert unsere GEZ ist mit rund 100
Leuten in diesem Land tätig es geht um
Beschäftigungsförderung um
Energieeffizienz um Reformen der
öffentlichen Verwaltung und um bessere
regionale Zusammenarbeit mit den anderen
Ländern im Westen des Balkans Dayton
gibt ein Stück Stabilität Christian
Schmidt leistet als Hoher Repräsentant
eine sehr sehr gute Arbeit aber die
ganze Lage ist fragil und deswegen
sollte dieser Jahrestag uns dazu bringen
aufzurufen zu mehr Engagement wir als
Europäer müssen aufgerufen werden zu
mehr Bereitschaft auf die Region
zuzugehen aber in dem Land muss
eindeutig auch mehr an Vorarbeit
geleistet werden wenn uns das gelingt
das Potenzial ist groß sowohl für die
Sicherung der Sicherheit wie aber auch
für die Entwicklung das ist gut für die
Menschen in Bosnien und Herzegowina das
ist am Ende aber auch gut für die
Menschen überall in Europa
so weit unsere Übertragung der
vereinbarten Debatte zum 30 jahrestag
des Kriegsbeginns in Bosnien-Herzegowina
was keineswegs nur eine Geschichtsstunde
war denn angesichts der Spannungen in
dem Land diskutiert die Bundesregierung
ob nun doch wieder Bundeswehrsoldaten in
das Land zurückkehren sollen als
Unterstützung für den dortigen
eu-einsatz eventuell sogar noch vor den
geplanten Wahlen in Bosnien-Herzegowina
im Oktober wir verlassen für heute den
Bundestag morgen sind wir natürlich ab
8:45 Uhr wieder da da wird es ein
richtigen abstimmungs-marathon geben und
eine große Debatte zur Impfpflicht Dirk
Wiese und Sepp Müller werden da vor der
Plenardebatte bei meinem Kollegen Gerd
Joachim von verlor sein und wir werden
natürlich das ganze Geschehen für Sie
hier begleiten jetzt begleitet sie erst
einmal mein Kollege Thomas badeweiter
und die Kollegen von der Tag
[Musik]
Sperranlagen
endmilitarisierte Zonen sie bedeuten
Trennung von Hab und Gut von
Gemeinschaft und sogar von Familien die
brachialen zeugen von Krieg Willkür und
Wahn reißen tiefe Wunden in die
Schicksale der Menschen die Mauern der
Welt erzählen die leitvolle oft blutige
Geschichte von gesellschaftlicher
Spaltung aber auch berührende
Geschichten vom Leben mit der Grenze von
Widerstand und vom Engagement für
Frieden und Versöhnung unsere Hoffnung
und Träume sind größer als diese Mauer
sehen Sie die Deutschlandpremiere der
sechsteiligen Reihe the wall Mauern der
Welt heute die ersten beiden Folgen in
der Doku Primetime bei Phoenix und schon
jetzt alle Folgen in den Mediatheken von
ARD und ZDF
[Musik]
Phoenix der Tag
willkommen zu nachmittagsausgabe von
Phoenix der Tag ja wir erwarten in
diesen Minuten Stellungnahmen von
US-Außenminister blinken und
Nato-Generalsekretär stottenberg nach
dem NATO-Außenminister treffen Moment
haben wir hier erstmal ein Bild vom
Regen in Brüssel vor dem
NATO-Hauptquartier aber sobald es soweit
ist werden wir live dabei sein die NATO
so sagt es dottenberg vorab rechnet mit
einem noch lange anhaltenden Krieg in
der Ukraine es gebe keine Anzeichen
dafür dass russlands Präsident Putin
seine Ambitionen aufgegeben habe die
komplette Ukraine zu kontrollieren die
30 Außenminister der Bündnisstaaten
warnen man müsste sich bewusst darüber
werden dass der Krieg möglicherweise
noch viele Monate oder sogar Jahre
andauern können den Rückzug russischer
Truppen aus dem Norden der Ukraine
erklärt es dorttenberg mit einer auch
nato-erkenntnissen geplanten
Großoffensive im Osten die Streitkräfte
sollen demnach verstärkt und neu
bewaffnet werden um gesamten Donbass
einzunehmen und eine Landbrücke zu
bereits besetzten ukrainischen Halbinsel
Krim zu schaffen und Konsequenz aus den
Entwicklungen ist laut doldenberg man
müsste die Ukraine unterstützen
Sanktionen aufrechterhalten und die
eigene Verteidigung und abschränkung
Stärken ein Blick auf den heutigen Tag
das ist gerade ihr Alltag wie hier in
andriwka sichert die ukrainische Polizei
in der Region rund um Kiew Beweise
Beweise die Kriegsverbrechen russischer
Soldaten belegen sollen
wir identifizieren Opfer befragen Zeugen
und dokumentieren die Fakten
im Butcher trauern die Menschen um ihre
getöteten Angehörigen viele stehen unter
Schock
experten versuchen Munition zu
entschärfen und zu beseitigen
Russland bestreitet weiterhin für die
Gräueltaten in der Ukraine
verantwortlich zu sein Belege liefert
der Kreml nicht ein Sprecher zeigte sich
heute unzufrieden mit dem Verlauf der
Friedensgespräche
der Arbeitsprozess geht weiter aber um
einiges zäher als wir es gerne hätten
wir wünschen uns mehr Dynamik von der
ukrainischen Seite
der ukrainische Präsident selensky war
heute der gesamten russischen Führung
Kriegsverbrechen vor und forderte
weitere Sanktionen
silensky betonte jedoch dass es ohne
Verhandlungen schwer seit den Krieg zu
beenden
es geht nicht darum ob wir diese
Gespräche führen wollen oder nicht wir
kämpfen für unsere Menschen und müssen
alles dafür tun um ihre Leben zu retten
nach ukrainischen Angaben soll es heute
11 fluchtkorridore für Zivilisten
umkämpften Städten geben im Osten des
Landes wächst die Angst vor neuen
Angriffen der russischen Armee ein
Sprecher des ukrainischen Militärs
erwartet russische offensiven in den
Regionen Donezk und Johannes
und Generalsekretär Stoltenberg hat sich
durchaus schon geäußert am frühen
Nachmittag bei der Ankunft vor dem
Hauptquartier der NATO in Brüssel hat er
schon einmal kurz zusammengefasst was
die wichtigsten Punkte dieses heutigen
Gesprächs mit den 30
außenministerinnen und Außenministern
sein werden und auf welchen Zeithorizont
wir uns bei der Ukraine einstellen
müssen das hatte ich vorhin kurz
angedeutet lassen sie uns da einmal
reinhören aber es könnte sein das
während Stoltenberg jetzt diesen
sogenannten doorstep uns liefert
möglicherweise haben schon die
livepressekonferenz beginnt also seien
Sie nicht irritiert wenn wir dann
plötzlich umspringen sie verpassen auf
jeden Fall nichts
erleben müssen die in deutscher begangen
worden sind und möglicherweise auch an
anderen Orten der Ukraine
hier offenbart sich die wahre Natur des
Krieges von
präsidentinent und hier umbringt dann
ist das ein Kriegsverbrechen die
Verbündeten der NATO unterstützen darum
unsere Bemühungen alle Fakten
aufzuklären zu ermitteln und dafür zu
sorgen dass die Täter ihre Strafe
erhalten
wir stehen jetzt in der kritischen Phase
des Krieges Russland zieht Streitkräfte
aus dem Norden
ableider verstärkten neu versorgen neu
mit Waffen ausrüsten um sie dann im
Osten einzusetzen
da erwarten wir eine große Offensive
Zettel Controller
versucht offensichtlich den gesamten
dornbuz zu beherrschen oder eine
Landbrücke hier zu stellen zwischen dem
Don Bass und dem Süden
House dafür gesehen dass Präsident Putin
seine Absicht geändert hat die gesamte
Ukraine zu beherrschen zu kontrollieren
und die Weltordnung umzuschreiben wir
müssen also auf eine langzeitentwicklung
uns einstellen die Ukraine unterstützen
unsere Sanktionen beibehalten und unsere
Verteidigung und unsere Abschreckung
stärken das Ganze kann noch lange dauern
und wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
story-minister Kollege from your prayer
der Außenminister der Ukraine ist zu uns
gekommen und ich finde es wichtig dass
du diese Gelegenheit halten und direkt
mit ihm zu unterhalten mit ihm zu
diskutieren ihm gehört zu schenken und
darüber zu sprechen wie es gemeinsam
vorangehen kann weitere Partner sind
auch dabei gewesen der Außenminister
Georgiens die Vertreter Finnland
Schwedens und der Europäischen Union
darüber hinaus unsere Partner aus dem
asiatisch-pazifischen Raum Japan
Südkorea Australien das sind allesamt
sehr hoch einzuschätzende und sehr
wertvolle Partner die Außenminister
werden heute Abend über das neue
strategische Konzept der NATO sprechen
bei diesem Konzept wird es natürlich um
die neue sicherheitsrealität gehen vor
der wir stehen
das strategische Konzept wird den Kurs
der NATO künftig bestimmen und deutlich
machen wie wir uns in einer gefährlichen
Welt verhalten damit wir auch weiterhin
alle NATO Verbündeten